Going to the contender after Freddie Roach.
Yeah.
Nice live.
Boom.
We're live.
You going to wear headphones or no?
Yeah,
it's better I get this right.
Do you wear or your cauliflower ears?
They keep you from wearing earbuds.
You know those little things that go in your ear.
Does I need to it?
No,
I don't need it.
You don't need it?
I don't know.
I don't have to just keep this goes to your face and we're good.
All right.
There we go.
What's up man?
How are you?
Fantastic.
He'll good.
I feel good.
And I feel that if it wouldn't be for my,
uh,
I like,
all sort of that ad that I would be if I feel better than,
than I when I was 25.
What did,
what did you have you had colitis?
Yeah.
Called ideas yet.
What is that?
What causes that?
We don't really know what it causes it,
but,
uh,
the best,
the best tre is that,
uh,
before my last fight with Michael Bisping,
I tried to put on weight extra weight.
So I followed a diet program that I was eating every,
almost every two hours.
And um,
I think our system is like a car,
you know,
if you do a lot of mileage,
it overuse it and said that's what happened with distress and everything.
During my training camp at big problem,
you know,
I couldn't sleep at crazy cramps,
sometimes add blood.
Even when I went to the bathroom at one point I had to go do some tests because
I was worried that it was something more like,
I mean it's,
collider is very serious,
but that it was like cancer or something because he had blood.
So I did some tests.
It came out and they get to live and I said to myself,
I said,
this fight been delayed,
delayed,
but postponed so many times that if I do something I,
if I say that perfectly,
what is going on,
I'm going to lose the opportunity to fight for the title at one 85.
So I keep it shut and I told myself,
said it,
whatever it is,
I'll deal with it after the fight.
So I did the fight.
Everything went well.
Then after I went to do a,
it's called a colonoscopy,
they put a camera inside of you and I did.
I got diagnosed with ulcerative colitis.
That's probably the mix of distress and also the,
the fact that I was constantly eating,
I was eating and not only eating Joe,
I was trying to put on some weight.
It was very hard.
Sometime I was,
I remember many times I was having breakfast but I was regurgitating,
regurgitating my breakfast.
Oh like chewing up cause you're just eating too much food,
but add to it because I needed to keep my seven a certain weight and definitely
the crazy thing about it is first not realize it's a mistake.
I should never have done it,
but when I made the weight at the one 85 the day before the fight,
I could not go back up to a one 90 that's a,
the higher side was going back up so that they have that fight.
I,
I woke up and I added a little breakfast.
I chew up my breakfast again.
Wow.
Yeah.
Wait,
I was really messed up.
Then I went to weigh myself.
I was like one 91 wow.
Yeah.
And what do you think Mike Wade,
you felt very strong.
I mean it's not really the weight at this time because
the way that you weigh right now,
depending on what you eat,
you have a lot of stuff inside your,
your,
your intestine and everything.
So you,
and also water retention.
I felt like add a lot of water retention and um,
unnecessary weight.
Yeah,
exactly.
So it's like dead weight.
It's like a bag that you would carry it on your shoulder show.
What I should have done,
I think is just stay the same way that I am.
My natural weight.
I think the buddy has a way that it's best way to perform an athletic
performance and that's what I should have done.
But it was a mistake of my part.
It was a big mistake.
So you were just thinking that because you're going up to one 85 and you're
fighting a guy in Bisbing that used to fight at two oh five.
Exactly.
It's a pretty big guy.
That I taught that to,
to perform better.
I needed to elevate my weight.
But by doing that,
I create,
I create the big problem of [inaudible] healthy.
She was so,
and that,
that colitis didn't exist before that,
eh,
not that I got diagnosed for no,
no,
at being that,
that's what trigger it.
And so after the fight,
now they've gone back to a normal diet.
Has it changed?
So,
so after that fight,
what happened?
And it's very interesting too,
I got an on medication and I met the doctor that his name is Jason Fung is
intermodal people can research,
has this amazing,
amazing guy.
And I met a doctor that,
that treat people with cancer and diabetes with a intermitted fasting.
So I started doing a program of intermitted fasting and time restricted eating
and all my symptoms diminish like every,
every week,
every month diminish.
So he's got,
it's getting better.
It's not 100% now,
but he's getting a lot better,
a lot better.
And I fill out a lot better.
A lot of people eat like that.
Now.
We had Ben Greenfield on yesterday who,
uh,
you know,
he's a,
a journalist,
does a lot of experimenting with his body,
thought a lot,
a lot of scientific stuff and it scientific,
uh,
research on diet and restricted eating is a big part of it.
He does a lot of that.
It's interesting because we're conditioned to think that,
oh,
I want to,
I want to gain muscle,
don't want to get,
you know,
I need to eat more to accelerate my metabolism.
But I never felt better in my life if we would not be for that particular issue.
I feel better now.
I sleep better.
Uh,
I,
uh,
inflammation and I'll also did a test in January.
I went to McGill university to do a scan of my,
uh,
my weight,
my purse,
my fat person at age,
my,
uh,
muscle density,
bone density and my,
I'm in five months.
I did it that few days ago,
like not letting that this week,
the Tuesday of that last week and my,
uh,
my fat person,
that dish has a decrease.
My muscle mass has and my weight is at the same.
Then it was in January.
And you think this is all from restricted eating?
My,
my training didn't that have to change?
So they only thing has changed pretty much is the,
the,
the restricted restricted at time eating and interpreted.
Fascinating.
Yes.
Yeah.
That intermittent fasting gives your digestive system a break and it lets your
body recuperate better.
I think that that's what had helped me out a that mostly I think that's what it
is a it I felt like I was like,
like I,
like I said,
like a car,
I was putting too much for nothing.
And I think as human being,
we're overfed.
I,
uh,
I'm very interested about paleontology and,
and also,
uh,
his story.
And I know that human being in anther gatherer time then that eat three meals a
day.
No,
they,
they maybe a few times a week.
But when they eat they eat a lot because I need to do with fat.
So I think it's more natural for a human being to do so.
And also,
I,
I now I read a lot of stuff and I watch a lot of stuff on the Internet.
How about intermittent fasting and time restricted aid eating.
And I just wish I knew that before,
uh,
for so many years.
I,
I used to follow the rules are we need to eat at least three times a day.
And,
you know,
I don't really care of what I eat,
but I,
I've,
even though in the morning I w I was not hungry.
I was always,
am I forcing myself to eat,
which is bad,
you know?
Yeah.
What,
what has changed in your diet?
Like what do you eat?
Like what's a,
what's a normal meal for you?
Ah,
no,
I don't really,
I don't really watch what I eat and Mr I,
I,
it's more a,
when I eat,
uh,
I tried to eat the Lt,
but I don't have a specific diet.
Like for example,
like,
oh,
she was the,
I'm going to eat this,
this,
that's on how it works.
Uh,
I just tried to eat lt,
you know,
like I,
I,
I tried to eat good and,
uh,
of course I don't look at,
oh,
there's a desert.
I'm,
you know,
if I wanted the SR chocolate,
I'll,
I'll get them over that from one of your old videos,
like you were having a glass of wine during training camp.
You're like,
oh,
so wasn't wrong.
One glass of wine while they think about it,
it,
I don't think glass of wine or anything,
let you know before I fight where we have the tendency to be too much.
Like,
oh,
what should I eat?
What should I do this,
they should I do that?
I think it's,
man,
it's a tense to 10.
So I've met,
when I went to in Thailand,
I met some,
some world champion Thai boxer and they smoked.
They get drunk before the fight.
I'm like,
you're fighting tomorrow man.
It's like,
it's like,
ah.
It's like,
it's no problem.
But when you think about it,
this is an extreme.
This is to the other extreme.
Yes.
But I don't think it as that much of an effect at,
you know what I would,
I used to eat before like before a fight,
my meal of choice,
before I got into reading about,
uh,
eating and stuff like that.
I was eating a pastor before,
uh,
before fight most of my fat.
I like fit to fit two cine Alfredo.
Hi again.
That's a lot of carbs.
I mean it seems like not that bad.
I mean it's,
it's not bad,
but I,
if you eat,
if you talk to her,
for example,
a nutritionist will be like,
oh my God,
it will grab his head will be you serious.
So my dice and you state that see Steeda steak and pasta before his fights,
that,
that was my thing.
I used sweet pass all the time and then there's no problem with that for me.
And I felt great.
But since I,
I start reading about nutrition and stuff like that,
it's like,
oh,
you need to eat clean and an m like it never affect me.
I don't think it as that much of a big,
big effect.
You know,
it's more psychological I think.
Well it's also you think about how much energy you're burning and I think for
the average person,
a bowl of pasta is not a good idea.
But for an athlete that's about to fight five,
five minute rounds against a world class fighter,
the ut of different energy requirements,
you know,
you have different nutrition requirements,
you can burn off way more fuel.
You know,
like I was listening to Chad Mendez and a podcast the other day and he was
talking about how he's so hungry.
He eats so much that he has to wakes up in the middle of the night and he goes
and eats sometimes.
Wow.
He just can't.
He can't go a couple of hours without eating.
He just has this crazy metabolism.
You know what says?
I discover time restricted eating and intermittent fasting.
Now I feel better by a training with an empty stomach and sharper up here.
I feel more creative,
especially in Jujitsu.
I feel better if the lighter on my feet.
You do like first Jiu Jitsu class in the morning?
No,
no food in your stomach and never have a food.
I haven't eat today.
This isn't,
but the coffee you give me is the first thing I have.
So when will you eat?
It's 1224 right after this.
I'm gonna.
I'm going to go train with Freddie Roach and then I'm an elite and AI and maybe
I'll eat another time.
I,
I'm a late eater.
That's one thing.
I'm not too good and I don't like to eat too much earlier during the day and
they're really hungry.
I used to eat because everybody eat.
But now I'm an I,
I'm not gonna eat this as I have.
I've discovered this.
I don't eat when I,
when I'm not hungry.
And the thing is why people eat is because they're a spike of insulin,
you know?
So when you like when I started doing intermittent fasting and time restricted
eating,
it was hard in the beginning because I was conditioned to eat all the time,
but my buddy acclimate to it and now it's very easy.
I can eat once a day.
It's no problem.
Like right now,
you know,
I could do it.
And I think it's good to be hungry in a way that I remembered.
A doctor has said something to me.
He said,
would you rather be like,
uh,
a lion that just,
add a full belly or an angry lion?
I'm like,
as a fighter,
I'd rather it be like a hungry lion and it makes sense to me.
If you look at nature,
it makes sense.
You know what I mean?
It doesn't make sense.
Especially when you do time restricted eating,
your,
your body gets used to burning off fat too and using fat as fuel.
It's true.
That's why I think when I did the test to compare my,
uh,
my phot percent,
they just diminish and I dealt with have much fat but it diminished.
And the doctor I met,
uh,
east,
I says to him and said,
yeah,
again,
a lot of weight.
He said,
you handled,
you think I'm going to lose muscle.
He says to me,
he believed that the way that I put on,
because now I'm about 185 pounds.
And I,
when I joined for Bisping,
I went up to 197.
And when I,
after,
after their way and I was,
I couldn't put back that weight up to wasn't 190.
He believed that the extra weight that ad was more water retention and um,
residual inside my and my buddy,
it was not like a solid mass and it makes sense to me because now I feel much
better and I'm just as strong and even stronger.
Like when I do Olympic lifting much stronger,
I'll a gymnastic much longer.
Like I feel sharper.
Yeah.
And you said it reduced your inflammation as well?
It does.
Avid sometime elbows,
you know like you used to have always that big inflated elbow.
Yes.
Swollen elbow.
What was that a was a
bursitis or birthday.
It was my birthday.
That was during my fight of the Jaguar vets,
but the,
I got to get a surgery to take her with the,
there is a draw the bone,
a chip inside my elbow,
isn't it from landing elbows or I think is just use users using it.
But now I don't have any problem anymore.
I don't want to feel like,
it used to be be a chronic thing that I used to feel some once in a while.
Sometimes it came and it goes,
but since I started this,
it didn't game at all.
I felt great.
I can touch my hair,
my to shoulder like this.
No.
Came back.
It's very interesting because with a lot of people they take time off and then
they come back and you wonder what they're going to look like.
But one of the things that I was very hopeful with you is that you've always
been almost a martial artist first and a fight or second and that you're always
learning and you're always practicing like you will.
You would always take time in between camps and you would,
you know,
do Jujitsu in Brazil or you would be constantly practicing your Moitai.
You're always trying to learn and improve your game.
And I was thinking when you came back and was like,
if you were saying that you are better than ever,
I'm like man,
he might be better than ever.
Like you.
You were willing to one guy that I believed because a lot of times guys come
back and like,
man,
he's been out of the game a long time.
Who knows how hard he's been training because a lot of fighters when they're not
in camp,
when they're not preparing for a fight,
they don't,
they don't like to train that much cause they,
they the,
the,
the grind of camp almost.
Where's I'm like,
you know how you see a lot of fighters after they retire,
they get really fat.
Yeah.
And you're like,
wow,
how could he get fat?
Like I was looking at my Donna the other day,
there's a picture of my Donna's um,
uh,
Chino,
Mondo Madonna.
He's got a Instagram page.
He's fat as fuck.
He's got a sick car.
He's drinking a whiskey.
Me,
he just fought Floyd Mayweather a couple of years ago.
He was ripped and this,
they retire.
They don't give a fuck anymore though.
I don't want to do this anymore.
But you,
I knew you were still
training cause I would see like an the Henzel Gracie,
the guys who were training with you there and I knew you were training with
Donna her.
I knew you were constantly training and you look good.
So I was like that when I left off like more than four years ago.
I,
uh,
I knew I wanted it to come back.
Uh,
the guy was not in an APP.
You place had a lot of personal problems and I should have even stopped earlier
than that after my fight with Hendricks.
If,
if I would have stopped earlier,
I would have maybe come back earlier as well.
Uh,
it was,
I was,
I felt like I was like kind of a feeling of a cluster claustrophobic feeling,
you know,
like it,
I was,
I couldn't breathe well.
I couldn't sleep well.
I,
in my mind,
I too much pressure or personal problem.
There's so much stuff,
a lot of stuff happened to me that it's still too early in my life and for the
respect of some people I know I couldn't talk about it.
One day I will all mixed together.
I knew it was a drug issue in the sport.
I feel,
I felt it.
I did filter well and uh,
I was trying to perform under those condition and it was catching up to me and,
um,
I did it.
But the reason why I think I didn't lose the edge is a lot of people,
because we do an extreme sport,
it's like what we do is kind of a life and death situation.
It's not because there's a referee,
but the spirit is the same as a gladiator,
gladiator or a person in a war that goes toward,
he thinks he's going to die,
is the same spirit,
even though he's not as anything.
But we'll go over there and the same spirit they were ready to give it or give
it all is such an extreme feeling that wants.
You don't have that,
then your life life kind of become boring.
You feel like you're not alive anymore.
So that's why when people step,
they retired and I tried to come back.
A lot of the people they fall into drugs because I want to catch up to that.
They want to feel alive again.
So they want,
they need that sensation that they add previously,
but I couldn't get it back.
And as they do drugs or they do something crazy extravagant,
the thing with me is I knew I was going to come back.
Uh,
and also I always like to train and keep myself in shape and I never did drugs.
You know,
like I never did drugs.
I drink,
I drink sometime.
If my birthday last Saturday I went out and I was completely wasted.
Okay.
It is what it is.
I like to deter rate myself sometime.
I'm not perfect.
Just have a little fun.
Exactly.
And I,
what's the goal of doing this?
If you're not enjoying her life?
What's the goal of it?
Right.
And no people to fight.
It's like,
no,
I don't like to fight.
And that was another thing I liked to talk to you about people's like what do
you do that if you don't like to fight?
And it's like,
because I like my lifestyle,
you know,
that it gives me,
but that's why people I believe will come back to what you would say.
That's why I think people,
they have a hard time to come back after so many years because they fall into
that they need to feel alive.
So they,
they,
they find ways to make them feel alive.
But it's the,
it's the interior.
They tell you your rate themselves neither.
I didn't do that.
I did not do that and I wouldn't never will.
Hopefully it's not my thing,
you know?
So when you decided to come back,
how far out did you decide?
Like,
but you,
you,
you took four years off.
How many years in where you were like,
I think I'm ready to come back.
Uh,
when I see USA USA DEA and the drug testing program being implemented and
implemented,
then I saw a lot of deflate.
Yes.
You feel like it.
Did you feel vindicated when you saw like some of these people just,
I feel a little bit of a,
I mean it feels bad to wish people bad luck to get some kind of recognition,
but that's not what I want.
I want to do.
I don't wish people bad luck,
but if you cheat,
you cheat man.
And they,
lot of people get cut.
And finally,
a lot of people in the beginning,
including my own friend,
they think like I was talking to some of my own friend that they say,
oh,
you're paranoid.
You become paranoid.
You need to take a break.
You,
you're going crazy.
Just retire or get out.
[inaudible] you're paranoid.
Because I was talking about it a long time before Hendrix and they had,
everybody was disregarding me but not in when it happened.
A lot of it that champion fell and then a lot of the role in the sport,
they got pointed out with the fingers,
hey,
he's a cheater.
So now it become real.
So when I saw that happen,
it was,
it was for me a beginning to start and now it's time to come back.
You know,
because I'm,
I'm a guy have of,
uh,
if I said something,
you know,
that's become going to,
I'm going to do it.
I didn't want to come back when the sport was dirty.
That's one of my thing.
And so when I,
when I,
the site to come back,
I had a big talk with one of my trainer,
John Than Rna and Ferris,
there were my two main guy and they're like my friend,
I brought her with me.
I mean I'm undefeated with these,
with these two guys,
you know,
and they,
they're like,
well I need them when I fight series knowledge between those two men and they
mixed together is crazy.
You know,
there are two different person,
very different.
They both have a um,
um,
they both studied philosophy.
It a variant and trusting people for me to talk with because I have two
different mentalities,
you know,
they see the world different ways.
So I like to,
to have both of their expertise and um,
so John,
John,
he told me,
he said,
listen,
he said you always have tree big criticizing,
criticize us when you were fighting.
It just never went up.
A weight class you never,
you,
you people say is that you kind of borrowing or too much cerebral with
technical.
You,
you don't want to take on SSA rerelease which make the fight boring and also you
finish your appointment.
You know,
that was one of my big criticizing criticizes.
I decide to come back and we change our,
um,
the way I was training because that the way you train reflects the way you
fight.
You know,
people say,
Oh,
I'm gonna,
I'm not gonna train too hard,
I'm going to do this and training,
but when I,
it's time to five,
I'm going to step up.
There is no step up.
You're just gonna do what what you did everyday,
you know,
investment.
So I decide to change a few things and uh,
to correct those three things and that's what happened.
And you know,
I'm,
I'm happy it worked.
It worked out well,
but that was my goal.
I wanted to come back for something that excite me,
something that was different,
something that was unique and rare,
you know,
and,
and I didn't want to come back to do the same thing I was doing before and
that's why I decided to come back.
When you came back,
first of all,
you came back and fought a very tough guy,
right?
You fought a big Michael Bisping at 185 pounds.
But what was impressive to me,
it's like you,
you didn't look like you were gone.
Like,
like right away you,
it felt like you felt right back into the groove again.
You didn't look out of place,
you didn't look uncomfortable and you were showing things,
especially different things with your kicking and your movement that we hadn't
seen from you before.
Like you looked like you had improved.
I was tested and then the training,
uh,
even Ferris,
some of the guys for the rest went to tell them like he whispered to them as,
hey,
if you knocked out with George inspiring,
I'll give you money.
Or you know,
things like,
yeah,
man,
he's crazy.
He's crazy.
If I rest is my worst enemy in training sometimes,
you know,
he tell Diet,
he tells people,
it's like,
hey,
if you,
if you beat Jay for you heard George,
I'm going to glorify you.
You know,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna.
Wow.
I'm going to talk about you and you know,
hey,
we're going to be IP because that's the opposite of what a lot of people think
of training camp should be for a champion.
It depends on what kind of,
you know,
we don't train like this everyday,
but for my heart sparing,
I've,
when I'm training for a fight of two days,
uh,
for my last training camp at two days that it was like hard sparring that was
called,
we called it shoot bucks.
Fight should shoot bucks fighting,
which we put the big loves the Shin Pad and his feet to floor.
Once we touched the floor we stop and we go back up.
And that was the area of expertise.
We're Bisping was the most uh,
uh,
competent.
The striking department he's going to at that floor is why I uh,
I,
I was,
I was bringing in a lot of good guys for aspiring with Mia and in,
in that,
that and that particular training,
it's hard to find someone that is exactly like,
like are you going to fight?
But you can find that guy that does things better than him in that particular
area.
You know,
I cannot find a replica of Michael Bisping was complete as much as Michael
Bisping fight.
Again,
find a guy,
for example,
I gave for coming from Spain is,
his name is Cesar.
He's a k one fighter and he's big guy like 205 pounds and he's big and he's just
very,
very good kickbox so,
so add him.
During my training camp,
I flew him from Spain at a different bunch of guys that I,
that I,
that I was training with and all of these guys that I was training with there
are not like Michael Bisping,
but in a certain area that I was training with them.
It could be grappling or Shush,
shush should box or a different different area there.
There could be just as good or maybe better than Michael Bisping.
So that's how I do my training camp.
You know,
I remember when you brought,
how do you say his last name?
[inaudible] not Charlotte Scott Buskey.
Yeah.
When you are that character,
the character in deed,
when you brought him to work with you on the ultimate fighter and he would be
partying all night drunk and show up at the gym the next day and still fuck
everybody up.
Yeah.
And did that
influence your,
this,
your idea about just being more relaxed and training and just not worrying about
it as much?
Yeah,
but he's at the front.
Like it,
it's a total different extreme,
you know,
like,
like I don't believe in that extreme,
but Scholly.
Yeah.
I remember the producer of their show with the ultimate fighter when he was,
is how about you were supposed to stay one week.
And when he was about to say,
the producer was telling me,
hey,
can we keep him for the rest of their show because it was a good TV,
you know,
so I'm like,
I don't know,
I'm going to ask him.
And,
and the in the same time,
like it,
a lot of the people in my thing,
they were like,
man,
okay,
that's enough.
Now we got what we need and that,
and I was like,
yeah,
I like him,
but he's just kind of a,
you know what,
I need to kind of babysit them and this idea of dying.
But the knowledge that this guy ad and he gave us was just a big,
a big edge,
you know?
And,
um,
but as I shot is a different extreme.
A Joe I take there is a center line that you need to keep,
you know,
uh,
that's what I believe.
I believe in life.
It's not white.
It's not black.
It's always grade there.
There's middle zone for everything I believe.
Yeah.
No,
I think you're right about that.
So when you,
when you have a camp and you set up a camp and you have Donna,
her and for Ross,
did they essentially,
uh,
or they are the architects of the whole camp,
do they get together and try to figure out what you're doing and when you're
doing it and how is for Ross,
the guy who handles like more of the striking aspects of it or putting the
grappling and the striking together?
I,
I am a little bit the head guy in a way.
You know,
I,
I believe as a fighter you need to be the guy.
You're,
you're the maestro.
We have the people that work like with you and,
and,
but that you need to know how to use these people.
Good.
For instance,
I don't know nothing about business,
but I have uh,
agents that are there to Nigga shade five day.
Dave knows number,
they know a lot about the investment.
I have one to another guy he knows about fiscally is a,
is a lawyer in a is good for a tax report.
I don't know nothing but I know how to get the good people to help me for that
particular thing.
Right,
right,
right.
So Ferris and Joan for me are the most competent people that I can have to help
me going to fight someone because in John,
especially in the grapping area,
but Johnny is known he and grabbing
the difference with John and Feras,
that makes them very unique as trainers.
They not really on the trainers that are teachers and I would say the same thing
about Freddie Roach.
Same thing about free road down and you train or their teachers.
The way I structure my,
my training camp there is like a pyramid.
The first layer,
the fund,
the,
the fundamental.
The foundation is physical.
Are you in shape?
Are you a zero?
We are vo two Max.
Are you in shape?
Are you in good condition,
no injuries,
athleticism or you are an athlete or you're a good,
good athlete.
Does that physical layer,
this is the wider one.
Does the the bottom one,
it's like a pyramid.
Then it goes up one layer.
The technical layer.
Do you know what to do with your knowledge?
Do you know a non bar,
a defense to a triangle,
choke out to counter a jab or I'll,
do you know what the technical aspect or not in terms of knowledge of fighting,
that's where the trainer comes into play.
Also the physical,
the technical and a lot of the trainer,
they don't have the last layer or down the,
I have one of those or two of those,
but they don't want to have the tree layers.
That's where a fire as John and also I would say free Freddie and boxing comes
into play,
but in MMA,
especially for us and John,
the tactical layer,
which is the last one,
that's what separate contenders and champion.
There's a physical,
the technical and the technical.
Let's say we're equal.
We're the same person.
What can I make the difference between me winning against who are you winning
against?
Me As a tactical because we're the same person.
We're a complete replica word.
We're a clone that the difference is the tactical.
I will know how,
where I can take you out of your comfort zone and I can bring the fight where
I'm the strongest and and fight you to eliminate.
Eliminate The ads word that the fight we're will s was strobe.
The odds of me winning to my advantage.
That's where John and Ferris,
our master at this and Freddie Roach,
he's a master at this unboxing and that's why I'm so,
I feel just very,
very lucky to have these guy on with me in,
in,
in my corner because they,
they,
they are competent in these tree layers.
Physical technique,
technical and tactical,
which most strainer can have only one,
two or maybe they,
they don't have trees.
Very rare to find,
treat those,
the trainer who can do that,
these thing.
So when you get to the tactical layer,
is this something that you all agree on?
Do you discuss it?
Like when we are approaching a fight,
like say Michael Bisping,
like what?
How does,
how do you,
uh,
how do you do it?
You say this is what I see in his fights.
And then for Ross gives his input and John gives his input and then Freddie
gives his input.
Yeah.
And you start discussing what's the best way to handle it.
So,
so coming into that fight with Michael Bisping,
Michael Bisping was very well prepared.
It was very,
very [inaudible] as a very good team with Jason Parillo.
So we were expecting,
you always have to gauge also to know you and to know your opponent.
You know,
sometime knowing you open it is easier than to knowing yourself,
you know?
So we have to be relaxed,
realistic about your strengths and weaknesses and how you're going to match up.
I your appointment with Michael Bisping.
What mess mess me up a little bit is an and all of us is what we're expecting
Michael Bisping to come straight at straight at me,
tried to to take me out right away instead of that,
it was moving especially more in the second round.
So the first one was I was doing well,
but then the second round he started moving away and be more
instead of coming at me.
It was more trying to running our way from me and that's why I love people.
They had said to me as a man that big,
because I lost that second round against Michael Bisping and people was like,
man,
what happened to you?
You were you,
you seem like you,
you were,
you slowed down a little bit and it's only that I saw Donna is also at,
yeah,
I got hit with whatever we strong right hand,
right on the bottom by a guy who maybe outweigh me,
but 20 pounds,
you know,
so it slows them down when something,
not that my cardio was bad,
it's not,
my car was fine,
but did we get punched on the bottom?
It's still a man down and he caught me off guard.
He changed his strategy from round one to round two we became more like,
it was more like a runner instead of a hunter kind of guy.
And so he caught you with a counter shot.
What he did is very smart.
He couldn't get to me,
if you look at the replay of that fight with Michael Bisping,
he couldn't get to me straight to my head.
Was he trying to hit me with his jab,
with his trike,
tried to target my head,
but I was too fast for him.
So I don't know if it's his trainer or a hymn.
We decide to change.
So he decided to be like,
like a runner.
So I decide to try to chase him a little bit more.
And what happened to me,
he jab my,
my lead hand,
which square me,
and then he connected me straight on the,
on the Chin Wa and that same thing.
I was trying to throw a leg kick so it was a perfect time,
beautiful execution.
And I don't if he practice that,
but it was very well done.
Very smart.
Instead of,
I tried to target my head,
he jab my,
my,
my hand and hit me with the rear hand.
And that's why it hurt me.
It hurt me.
I tried to put that poker face on and during that five way did it me,
it's one of their strike that hurt me the most.
Even though Michael Bisping is not known as a knockout guy.
This,
this,
this shot really hurt me because of the precision was the timing was good.
I've never understood what people don't think he hits hard and we look what he
did to Rockhold.
He hits fucking hard.
It's,
I think it's wet hurt someone in a fight.
I mean,
what can put away someone isn't necessarily the power,
but it's more precision and timing.
And that particular,
uh,
Ryan was perfectly time and with great precision.
So that's why I got hurt.
And you win their second around,
then add to make adjustment for the third round.
And that's when fair.
Uh,
Freddie Joan and,
and uh,
for the rest come into play.
They were,
they saw what it was doing and they say after the Ryan just slip and come with
the hook over the top and the right hand.
And that's what I did.
And then the knock him down and,
but in,
in that fight,
whatever your trainer tells you,
if you didn't practice it,
it's,
it's not gonna work.
I mean,
you don't have time to think it's autopilot.
Yeah.
So I was on autopilot.
Sometimes you just need some,
some kind of guidance that put you back,
that put your autopilot in the right direction.
And that's what happened into that fight.
A reminder.
Yes.
I little reminder,
Aa,
we're not going this way.
We're going this way.
Okay.
Then you,
then it's still there with,
to pilot,
but it's different direction.
The crazy thing about Mike is,
uh,
he,
he has very poor vision in his right eye.
A lot of people might not know about it,
but in the Vito Belfort fight,
he damaged his retina very badly.
He's had several surgeries and he's got oil in his eye that's sort of like
protecting it and he'll have it fixed once he's done fighting.
But you know,
if you look at him,
one of his eyes is darker than the other eye and that's that right eye.
And did you particularly target things going to that right side,
like things off of your left side?
Yeah,
it's a lot of things that would drill done uh,
with the left hook.
That's why like when I,
when I hit him with a left hook that was a lot of,
he would have a harder time seeing things coming out of Heelys vision was more
blurry.
He does.
But the thing is with Michael is he adjust himself very well to this,
you know,
like,
like it's like a,
he knows it and probably knows it themselves,
but the way he fights he adjusted very well.
You know,
you put them self in a position that he cannot get hit often with this,
you know,
especially in the,
in my fights.
So I needed almost to wait for him to commit with the right hand to come over
the top.
And you look at that fight with Kevin and guests at them as the same thing he
missed with that right hand.
And then he get counted.
It's always when he missed with the right hand that he got caught carbon fight.
I think it was a mistake.
It wasn't a mistake because he was not preparer for this.
He didn't.
Right.
What's also,
he just got off of a crazy fight with you.
It was bad.
I think it was a bad mistake.
Farm.
I sparred but,
but look,
to his credit,
he tried to do something and that I do try to do all the time.
You tried to do something unique and very special and if you would have,
when we would not have this discussion we would have,
would be saying like,
man,
why did I come back?
It's unbelievable.
He lose a title,
come back straight to FICA,
Galvin gasoline and what's amazing.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You took a risk man and I can't blame him for it.
I took a risk myself too.
It's just sometimes you roll the dice,
you know when you expect things to go your way and it didn't go his way.
Yeah,
I felt bad,
but it is what it even,
he said that when he came out to that fight,
the Kelvin on fight,
he just didn't feel like he ha he just didn't feel there off.
Of course it didn't feel there because he didn't have the time to prepare for
this.
Like I said,
but you're not,
you're not going to go into a fight then and improvise everything.
You're going to do the same thing you've been doing in training.
What have you been doing in training?
He didn't have enough time to prepare for that particular type of buddy.
That particular type of of uh,
like I said,
physical,
technical and tactical,
which is that most important one.
You didn't have the tech that the tactical preparation physical was not prep,
prep,
prep and be 100% as well.
And the technical is there because this is brain,
but you know,
it's,
he didn't program is autopilot to react to a certain situation that Kevin will
give him.
It was,
he's a lefty,
shorter stockier,
you know,
different style than me.
Completely different.
It's like you couldn't have a difference.
A moat.
Amal.
Amal was different style than me and then this guy,
but he won the title that way.
One of the title on 11 days notice.
I agree.
It's like it worked for him in the past.
It went for,
it worked for him in that past.
But you didn't get knocked down or choked out before if I Ratko that messed up
your recuperation too.
You know what I mean?
He was fresh,
proud be,
I don't know.
Maybe he wasn't.
I don't,
I don't know personally where what he was doing,
but,
or was it,
he was not like maybe not even a month or something like that.
You wouldn't not have been clear to fight if it would have been in America.
I don't think it would have been cleared to site.
I think it would not have been clear to fighting.
It was suspended,
I think.
I don't think so because they don't think so.
I think they,
because it wasn't,
China is the maybe the three weeks.
Wow.
Three weeks.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
That seems pretty close.
Because you heard him with that left hook and then you choke them unconscious.
If it would be me,
me,
like maybe I don't,
I'm not as courageous as Michael Bisping.
I wouldn't have not take the fight.
Even me,
if I win the fight with Michael Bisping,
I wouldn't not take that fight the word though.
Courageous.
You're pretty courageous guy.
Is that grace or is it tactical?
Tactical.
I moved.
Not,
I would not have to take that risk,
that risk,
but it's,
I'm not in this shoe was,
I don't know.
Right,
right,
right.
These environment maybe would have,
the toughness is paid off for him though.
I mean,
he's one of the toughest fucking guys in the sport.
He always has been.
And that toughness is the reason why I was like,
fuck it,
I'll fight again.
That's do it.
He's just a fucking animal.
He is.
And he's a great example of hard work and perseverance and,
and,
and you know,
like when you say everything is possible is it is unbelievable,
unbelievable fighter.
This guy,
you know,
and as courageous and,
and what I like about him do we stand for the same thing then I stand for,
for against performance enhancing drug and I think is very important for me.
And for me it was like an honor to fighting him.
It was like a,
a lot of guy he lost to this guy that they would that have been cut on
performance enhancing drugs and,
and um,
he's very open.
He talks about it all the time and I think is great.
Great model for this part.
Yeah,
I know,
I agree.
And a great model for,
it's just an example of how you can achieve great things if you work hard.
Yeah.
And that's what he's done is he's one of that guy that like,
I hate him when I wasn't trying again,
but I loved them as well.
And the same,
same time.
I remember at one point,
at one point we were in the conference in Toronto and that is the largest story
I've heard at a conference.
We go back to back kind of the back door of a mall.
And,
um,
there's like a,
I don't know if it's a,
it was staged or not.
I,
I mean,
I'm not aware if it was stage,
I wasn't that aware of it.
So there's a camera around,
like I think he said was TMZ or something.
It was like,
Kimra,
that photo.
So there was kids following us too.
They're about to ask us.
The,
asked me to take pictures and then,
then I say camera coming towards me.
And then that's Michael.
That's after the,
the,
the governance and Michael the system.
He's a bill at you f book,
you're an on me again because then,
and then,
and then I look in his face and I was like,
what as I do it,
I'll put you back.
And then he create,
create gotta have a buzz word that fight.
And we started to shout at each other and it kind of almost boosts each other.
And Jerry [inaudible] is leave it fortified boy.
So,
but it's,
it's not stage.
It's true.
Now I'm like,
man,
what the hell he was doing there.
But then after I realize it go,
it was on TMZ where I came out right there.
Then they chose,
they came through asking me for another graph.
They can,
they can,
they kind of get um,
intimidating.
They were like,
they went back.
Then I turned around,
I was like,
it's okay.
It's Spanish and all you can come in and go.
They get where they went back to their,
if I write I'm like,
Oh God,
what?
It is what it is,
you know?
But that was probably the best promotion of the old fight,
like that particular incident,
you know what I mean?
So I hate him and I love him this same way.
Michael is kind of a guidance.
He's,
he's a pro at,
at boosting the anticipation for a fight hype.
You want to hate them,
but you kind of love him.
And then the same way for the,
the human being that he is,
you know?
No,
he's great at talking Shit for sure.
A,
that is a big thing these days.
I'm going,
especially after Connor,
Connor Mcgregor has kind of changed the sport and a lot of ways and that,
that shit talking is a,
is a huge factor now.
It is,
but sometimes you don't know when is really what it is.
Not because I'm,
I'm not,
it's not part of my personality.
And same thing at the Espn in Boston,
same thing.
We do an interview,
we go back and forth,
blah,
blah.
I kind of,
uh,
almost insulting each other.
So resource mean
then at the UFC does everything to separate us for me,
one of each other.
Like I'm like,
I don't know if it's real or not.
I don't even know if he's trying to push me.
I'm going to push him back cause I feel I felt threatening.
So you don't know if it's hype or myself because I'm not an instigator.
I don't like confrontation,
but it is what it is.
So I go to the bathroom in between.
Who comes next to the bathroom with us?
It's my [inaudible].
We're,
I'm,
we're taking a piss now,
next to each other.
We're like this.
Then I throw us Michael Microbus,
ally,
Holy Shit.
Then the camera at any telecom earth,
we twoF out.
As I get out there,
never camera goes out.
They look at me,
look at it.
Then he start laughing and then I start laughing.
Then.
Then I told him,
I said,
hey,
you get a range rover?
He's like,
yeah,
but now he's in the garage.
I'm like,
yeah,
it's a,
you need to get rid of it.
Because after a while it did start breaking down is I?
Yeah,
I know it was.
I came game phase two later.
I didn't want to hate I guy like this.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
that's hilarious.
But I hate him because when we insult each other,
we say real and salt and real things that we think about each other,
but in a way we have the respect.
Yeah.
So it's really,
but so with that relationship that I have with Bisping was very unique.
I didn't have the same relationship with [inaudible],
for example,
Diaz.
I didn't know if like if I meet him,
even the district too,
there may,
he hates my guts and I don't know what he's going to write.
I don't know if he wanted to fight me or he might not really want to fight you,
but he's not a hype guy.
I think he's,
I think he takes it personal and I think he,
it's man,
it's a Freakin spart man is more to life than what it is.
It was I all fighting his might now,
man,
fighting is not my life,
man.
My life is my family.
Man is,
is my friend.
The people I love.
This is what I do in my life is not my life.
I need,
the fighting is over,
it's over.
I turn around and do something else.
You know what I mean?
Like is what I do in my life,
some my life.
You know what I mean?
At the end of the world,
man,
this is more to life than fighting who.
It's funny hearing that from you because you would,
you would expect to hear that from someone who isn't considered one of the
greatest of all time.
But you're considered one of the greatest of all times.
So it would be very art.
It would be very hard to argue your approach because it's been so successful.
They,
they,
they got it.
That'd be super obsessed.
I'm super obsessed Joe,
but that's why I become crazy day and I stopped for four years and then when I
came back I,
I some of my circuit and the brains then I am,
I started to analyze myself and like,
why am,
why become crazy?
Why did I stop?
Because I'm taking this stuff too seriously,
man.
You have to take it for what it is,
you know,
like yeah,
it's a world championship fight.
I'm fighting.
I was fighting.
Michael made after four years be boom,
I got the fight are promoted on drama and like John said,
John Dinner,
he says is I fight are not one Andrae Ma r one r on mundane things than we do
every day.
That's how fight are one.
How you program it,
program your,
your,
uh,
your cruise,
your,
your cruise driver.
You're not doing your,
your,
your autopilot to win the fight.
That's how you me,
I see it a fight like an autopilot.
You know like so when I fight,
when I prepare myself for a fight,
especially with the tactical part,
I program like a computer out,
I want to react against that specific problem.
I'm going to take care of that,
that specific problem.
The only way to program it is to do repetition,
repetition and repetition and repetition and repetition.
It's like you said a one point the Eddie Bravo,
we said like tie,
tie,
tie up your shoes.
Cause we've been doing it so many times you can talk to someone.
The same thing when I get into a fight,
I analyze again and I'm fighting and I see what pattern he does the most often.
So I want to program my computer to react to that pattern that would give me the
advantageous to the fight.
I don't know what,
when that pattern,
when I occur,
when I want to program myself that when at Acura I have an answer for it right
away.
I don't have to think about it.
I don't think.
I just react and that's my problem.
When I used to fight and I got a lot of criticize them before I was thinking too
much towards the end of my carer at so much pressure,
I didn't perform as well as I was earlier,
especially my last fight before I stopped for the four years.
I was thinking too much overthinking too,
putting too much pressure.
Like you said,
it's too serious.
You have to take it for what it is.
It's only a fight in a 10 years,
you know it's,
you know,
it's sucks if you lose,
but man,
it is what it is.
You know what I mean?
Don't take it for,
don't make it bigger than what it is.
It's only a fight and sometimes it's something very therapeutic that I like to
do.
Before a fight,
I could drive a car.
Hey,
when I fight in Vegas,
for example,
I drive a car or a New York,
same thing.
I drive a car.
When I used to fight in Vegas bag before my fight,
I used to be very,
very stressed in one.
A very therapeutic things I that I like to do is drive my car around and see
normal people.
Then I go and I,
I explained to you why I drive an icy old lady with our grocery store bag is
that,
and I'm thinking it's like she doesn't care if I win the fight Saturday or not.
She's not even going to hear about it.
Then I look,
oh,
he's another guy yelling another guy because the whatever problem,
Oh,
this guy is going to the bank to pays his mortgage stuff and they don't care.
They don't care.
You know?
The effect that I have on the universe is so freaking small.
Nobody cares.
I'm the only one putting the pressure on me.
Nobody gives a damn about it.
So that's why they helped me to perform.
Now that's how some younger Getty,
I say,
oh,
they are nervous.
How do I heard you don't sleep well the night before I said,
yeah,
it's true.
I don't see well is how,
what is your trick?
How do you find a way to see?
Well,
it was like,
ah,
I don't really sleep well either.
Nowadays is how I'll do,
but how do you feel better about it?
Like I just know that I'm not going to sleep well and it's not going to affect
the outcome of the competition is just a normal thing.
You learn how to deal with it better.
You're not going to change it.
Just accept it.
Yeah.
Distress is your friend,
man.
That's gonna make you react.
There's going to be on the edge.
Have you ever slept well before a fight?
Never.
Only one time when I fought Matt Serra and I got knocked out
and then after that knocked out,
I got so scared.
I ended up and again is the most humiliating day of my career.
I was so angry.
Like I said,
it was like putting too much on myself.
It start there is,
I don't even want to go to to buy eggs at the grocery store because people are
these.
They look,
you get knocked out.
I taught.
Everybody cares about,
nobody cares about you.
Nobody cares.
It's only a small percentage of population.
Nobody gives a them.
And even if they do what you make a mistake,
you zig when you should have zagged you to get clips.
So what everybody make mistake,
you have to take fight like it is,
you know it's a sporting event.
That's why I don't take it personally.
Like I want to have the problem with the diaspora at no problem and is that
fight is not personal for me.
You're,
you're in my life now.
You won't be there in 10 years.
Maybe.
Maybe you will,
man,
I,
who knows.
It's only like a chunk of life that we share together and then after he's gone,
no problem with that.
That's definitely a better attitude to look at that.
That's the way it is.
That's all athletes they should think,
you know,
and that's that knowledge that I have is with years of years of competition,
all the,
the problem I have,
their colitis and all that.
That's because of that,
that,
that bs that I got it like putting too much on me.
It's normal.
And if I fight again,
it will be,
it will go back.
That same pattern.
I will,
I will not be,
I will be very stressed and it's normal to be stressed,
but I will accept it.
I accept it better now than I used to do when I was younger.
Now after you won the title,
there was thoughts of whether or not you would defend it if you were going to
fight Robert Whittaker,
like what you were going to do,
what,
what caused your decision?
What made you decide to relinquish the belt?
So the reason why I relinquish your belt is ag.
I went to do some physical tests to see what,
what,
what does that problem with my elk condition?
Because during the decap I knew ad problem.
I didn't know what it was.
I knew it was,
you know,
that that tests the blood tests and everything for the cancer.
He came negative.
So after I went to do like,
like I say,
a colonoscopy,
it came back that Adva.
Uh,
no sir.
Inside my stomach that has a doctor,
I say how long it takes to get rid of this is a,
is all your life.
But the symptom,
the symptom can go up,
down,
depending every people,
whatever they do differently.
Then I started researching who's the best doctor or I'll can I do this?
And that's when I start reading about like the fast thing and stuff.
And I,
and I then I,
then I tried it,
but
I saw that a lot of,
you know,
in that sport of MMA,
a lot of the guys are a starving day.
They don't,
they're not home,
they not rich.
You know,
I'm lucky now I have enough money for the rest of my life.
I don't need to fight anymore.
You know,
if I don't do nothing crazy like buying a private airplane and I'm not that kind
of person or falling into drugs and stuff and I,
I think I'm good,
you know,
for me,
my family and everything,
I think I'm good.
However,
at,
when I'm looking at the landscape,
I see a lot of guy,
like for example,
Connor Mcgregor,
you hold onto the title two to four,
the attention the sponsors at this and that.
And I love people do that,
that they kind of stole the division.
And I'd say I do my side.
I said,
you know what I stand for,
for the fighters always did.
You know,
and publicly as,
why am I going to keep that title until to see if I feel better or not and
defend it because I don't even know if my leg,
my weight was dropping down.
It's like I,
I'm not even a one 85 or a Memoriam one 70 or one 55 hours.
I'm not,
I don't have the size of a one 85 hours.
So I'm like,
I,
I relinquish it right away.
You know,
I don't want to install the division and make people wait because of me.
They're the,
well,
don't go around me.
You know what I mean?
So I,
for the respect I did,
I did it,
but I didn't know before the fight I was going to do it is it happened like
[inaudible] like this people,
I was like,
oh yeah.
You know,
not knowing.
No,
I did.
I didn't know he was going,
I didn't know it was going to have a call.
Ideas and all that stuff.
He,
it came up,
I never tried it before.
I didn't know what would be the outcome,
how I would feel.
I never did it.
You know,
it was a test and this I know,
but I didn't know.
You know,
I have a lot of them.
I'm not a perfect man,
and Joe have a lot of,
uh,
negative stuff about me.
But one thing that I'm not is that I'm not a coward.
This,
I swear,
if I say I'm going to do something,
I'm going to do,
I'm not a coward,
you know,
and every of my fight,
every of my fight I was,
I'm scared.
I'm terrified.
But whatever.
I feel I stepped and I,
and I,
uh,
I respect my contract and I do it,
you know?
And,
um,
I didn't,
I didn't know the colitis and all that.
It was,
it would be illogical.
Right now if we,
if I want to go back when I'm ready to go back one,
eight,
five,
I'm not one 80,
you know?
Right,
right.
It would be a stupid move.
And so if you're gonna fight again and it'd be one 70 or one 55.
Yes.
What,
where,
where are you leaning?
Are you leaning towards 55 or 70?
I don't know.
I'm Emily.
I'm gonna.
I want to lean.
We're,
if I want,
you know what?
I've climb the Everest many times.
You know,
I've climate.
Once I lose to Matt Hughes,
then I climate too.
I loosed,
I then I,
then I got it,
then I lose to Masada.
I climate again.
I've done it like three time and you're like,
I'm 37 years old.
I just turned 37,
few,
two days ago.
I don't have much left.
Right.
And for what I have left,
I want to make the,
the,
the big fight that fight that the fan want to see,
they want to enjoy.
Um,
I also want personally for me to achieve something that is unique,
that is rare,
that maybe that never been attempted before.
You know,
that would be something that excites me.
And I'm not only driven by money,
you know,
like,
Eh,
it's good to have money.
We like money.
It's,
it drives us all,
including myself,
but it's not the unique thing that drives me.
It need to be more than money and they need,
need to be some kind of achievement think that comes with it.
That would exciting me.
So what would that be?
That would be 155 pound title.
They,
they,
they offer me Nate Diaz note.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and uh,
it was,
uh,
it was a rumor.
They said it was a done deal.
It's not a done deal if not on my part.
And I don't think it was on Nate Diaz part as well,
because from what I've heard,
his brother Nick set,
and even Nate says,
that's his big brother,
his fight,
it's not his fight from Nick,
Nate,
Nate Diaz is,
it is I incredible fight are very well rounded.
However,
from,
if you put yourself in my shoes,
there's nothing good that can come out of it except money and money is not the
only thing that really drive me.
If I beat Nick Diaz,
Nate Diaz decisively,
some people will say,
ah,
most people would say,
oh,
you took an easy fight or whatever.
Like the,
the,
the criticize them,
we'll say to say,
ah,
he,
uh,
he's a bully,
you know,
155 yeah,
he fought that smaller guide that compete at a smaller,
maybe it's not even smarter than me.
Maybe we're about the most fifth one.
A lot of one 55 or the guys are bigger than me right now.
Nate's a big guy.
He's a big guy.
He's about that same size.
I mean,
but because I compete at one 74 most of my carer and you won the title of West,
it wouldn't make me look bad.
They will make me look like a bully and this is if I win decisively,
if I,
for example,
if I win,
not decisively,
if I wouldn't not get savoir back and forth,
that people was high,
you suck.
You cannot even,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
And if I got beat,
oh my God,
if I get it,
this format I guess is the end of the world is all the work I put in his finish
and I could have a bad day.
Yeah.
Something that I discovered during my career has been the strongest men in the
world as my,
that was my dream when I was young.
That's why I did UFC.
I want it to be the stronger men in the world.
And I realize over there it did not exist.
You cannot be the stronger men and their world.
This is an illusion.
I love the younger guy.
They said,
well,
the bad ass minute now you're not man,
it doesn't exist.
You would be strong.
You would be a better fighter than this guy and that particular day at that
particular location,
at that particular moment,
maybe in an hour,
if the I would occur an hour later or an hour before or maybe in a different
place where they,
the altitude desire or lower or the different scenario,
different environment,
you will lose that fight.
It's always that question of uh,
you know what I mean?
So being the stronger man in the world,
it does its style.
Makes fight.
Maybe were tree guys,
I beat you,
you beat him,
he beat me.
Who's us?
It was the best guy is no bad guy.
Right.
That's MMA math,
right?
It is.
It is like this.
That's the way to see it.
There is no stronger men in the world.
You can't,
you'll say,
oh,
I'm the baddest man on the planet because I'm champion.
Like the belting is is an illusion.
The belting belting is assemble,
but it's an illusion.
It doesn't exist.
You're not the stronger men in the world.
I know a lot of people will disagree with me,
but is it is what it is.
That's if you ask most experienced fighter,
most people would think the same way because we realize at one point like when
we're young,
because of our confidence or maybe are the cockiness or confidence after it.
Not that it fades,
but we,
we,
we see,
we have more experience and knowledge.
We rise.
They tell it's all bs.
It's not true.
So the UFC offered you,
Nate Diaz.
Did you consider it at all or was it like I say it,
I consider it however Aa,
I analyze it.
I talk with Ferris,
what my trainer and everybody,
we were all in the same page on death.
They say say Sally,
it's not,
it's not worth it.
But did the UFC announced it?
Did they say that they were working on it?
I think,
I think they announce it.
I'm not sure.
I think they said there was a done deal.
Look,
it's not our first time it happened and,
and I'm not the have a business to run their UFC and they're,
their biggest fear is someone take that title and run with it and has been,
I've been doing it two times with Johny Hendricks.
I know with that Michael Bisping like I run,
they say I run.
But as for the reasons,
you know,
there's always a reasons and,
and that's their biggest fear.
Sure.
So that the,
and I understand that they have a business to run.
It's by this,
it's like WWE when
g three the giant passed the torch to all Cogan.
He passed that torch because it's for an a business and he agreed to pass the
torch.
Yes,
but the thing in this,
in this,
in this part,
we're nothing.
Wwe is my life on the line here.
Yes.
I don't care about the business.
I do.
What is the best for my interest to me?
Sure.
You have to.
I have to.
I have to be selfish and I am selfish.
I say it opened the I am,
I say it to the fan.
I am selfish because it's a,
it's a sport that I can die.
You can die in this sport and this is the truth can get or not maybe not die,
but he could create,
create at your death and the next time to come in the next year,
maybe you get a blow that messed up something in your brain because of a trauma
that create the something else.
So it's a very serious sport man is,
is not like a,
you play hockey,
play baseball,
play football.
You don't play fighting.
So you do it for yourself.
You do what is best for yourself.
The organization will do what is best for the organization.
They're not your friend.
Right?
So that's why their relationship with Dana and some other guy in UFC,
it's a very special relationship.
Maybe one day we'll sit down and we'll talk about the good old day then and have
a blast.
Have a laugh.
But right now I always am always on the defensive.
When my phone rang,
I see that now way like God damn.
Then I say it.
What I should say,
what I should not say then and then,
uh,
and I'm completely honest about it is like some no man,
no,
just as I,
if you do this because you are needy yet if you do that,
if you just take any fight that fight in that name.
No,
I mean it doesn't work like that.
It's the ascension to be champion is not a straight line is this all is a nap
stakeholder.
Oh,
then you come back and that is it.
It is what it is.
And you need to be surrounded by smart people.
And if you don't want to have smart people,
you need to be smart enough to find those people that are competent,
that will help you in particular domain,
that you are not competent to make the job for you and complete your circle,
you know?
Yeah.
Dana was saying for a while that you didn't want to fight.
He was saying George doesn't want to fight.
He Sat,
he said before,
I didn't want to fight before I fought Bisping.
You know,
he said the life.
Why?
Why do you think you were saying that?
Do you think he was putting pressure on you psychologically?
It was fucking with your head.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so my ego would've made me,
I'll show you that I could fight brewing me.
This guy.
Right.
That's what it is,
man.
It's I freaking game.
It's all that game.
We say it's not a game.
It's real out.
It's all a game.
It's all business.
I like Dana,
Dana,
man.
This part was nowhere.
That sparked was government.
He didn't go nowhere because of Dana.
We hold Dana,
my living,
I hoe it to Dana white when I do the UFC Wayans when I introduced everybody,
I point to him,
I say,
Dana White,
without him,
none of this would be possible.
And you write a hundred percent a hundred percent ease that best pound for pound
promoter of all time.
I don't care about dunking.
Wherever you Dana White,
he's the best.
He's better than all sport included.
I never seen anything like this.
He can sell ice to an Eskimo if you want to ease an incredibly good fun.
And He's good at messing up with my head too because even though I,
sometimes my ego was like Nate,
Nate Diaz it because of their stuff he said to and the way they try,
I don't know if the UFC tried to make him say stuff because some fighters are
more like pond on a chest on a check check chess board and others.
Me,
I'm not,
I don't follow wind.
Everything analyze.
I'm thinking.
I was like,
why you say it that way?
Okay,
that's big.
So a lot of stuff had been setting my ego somehow.
Like,
man,
I want to say,
all right,
you think my schedule is too busy,
I'll take their far east.
No,
I kicked her out.
You know what I mean?
But I shall not do that.
This as Tupin move.
If I start acting like this,
I Barone and a lot of guys,
they don't have that self control and self discipline in them.
It's all that game,
man.
That's all that game there was a,
it's not,
it's all,
it's bs.
It's all a game.
Men,
it's all a game.
What did Nate say that fucked with you?
Okay.
And they'd be eyes and,
and nick.
Nick is like kind of together.
And then when they say that I took steelhead when I fought this brother,
uh,
I,
I messed up my glove,
my rap.
Um,
I didn't make weight.
And uh,
what did you say?
Oh yeah,
I put something in that in div of his brother.
So he said if I want to take care of it,
like if,
I don't know why you said it in his own like word,
like in English slang like Oh yeah,
if you want to take care of this,
I'm there.
You know,
all kinds of,
someone poisoned him.
Yes.
Who was was that for?
Which fight was that?
So at Anderson Silver.
Okay.
I gotta confess the Joe,
I got to confess,
I got to confess.
Okay.
I was,
I was so scared during this,
this fight.
So we tried to poison,
I was so scared of fighting Nick Diaz.
So we poison is ivy.
What the survived.
So it was even more terrifying,
you know,
so
all the athletic commission was on my payroll,
so they trade away and then I made it
and it went through.
So I was even more than verifier.
So the Elio and abduct me,
what that guy,
they put the Gay Gamma Ray do increase my strength.
Like the Oak,
that guy a performance enhancing drug and ended the fight was still happening.
So right before I put some glass and cement in my gloves,
make sure
and still add a crazy hard fight,
you know?
So I got to confess with Nick Mal,
but it's completely insane.
You know,
fight.
You said all that you said for my fight that I present is ivy,
that I was on steroids,
that I,
my,
my rap was wrong.
And you said also what,
what did he say?
That he said?
Yeah,
the,
the way and like,
I didn't make weight.
Like I w I tricked the athletic commission or they were on my likes total today.
Is it just when he is,
I think he's,
he's,
he has a,
he has a problem of a consideration.
Consideration to eat,
to eat.
Take everybody's against him,
you know,
paranoia.
Yes.
I think that's what it is.
That might be the weed.
It could be weed.
You know,
I don't wanna I don't wanna say nothing.
Vida are weighed that take bubba,
but we'd like all things can be good,
but also can be Buckeye.
Okay.
I know you're,
you're afforded a weed stuff.
I've,
I do enjoy weed and you're a smart guy.
You'll have much better argument than I in R four four that time we'll use
though of everything,
including drinking.
Right.
I like a drink every now and then.
I like pot.
I don't think you should smoke it all day,
but I think that's why it is.
I think we,
I don't if it's a weed,
but I think it's maybe we'd social environment or and genetic can create some
kind of disorder disorder in,
in the brain and make you have the inspiration,
conspiracy problem you think everybody is against you,
isn't good,
good happen.
And the could happen.
I've seen a lot of my friend,
we smoke a lot.
They have this problem.
Sometime they think they can't,
they paranoid.
Yeah.
I think it's like all things you do too much of it.
It can fuck with your head.
Everything could be good or a bad thing.
Now I'll you use.
Yes.
So what fight is interesting to you?
There's this talk of Khabib at one 55 was the champion now and Connor.
Those are the two fights that I hear right?
Right now.
Right now as we speak now.
I wouldn't want not won't right now to put myself immediately in a training camp
because the reason is my symptom is not gone.
I ate your colitis a fill a little bit.
It's not,
it's not as bad as it was.
Not even close.
It's much better,
but I want to get the rear of it before I get into a training camp before I got
put myself into a stress cause that stress what it does,
it amplify everything.
So if you have like little issue is that it will amplify it and at least I need
to take care of that is my,
my lt is an bus in front of my performance in sport.
This is why we're important and when I'm ready like I don't know,
I may,
I would like go something like I said,
unique,
rare,
something that is reared that never been done before.
That would be a 55 con champion should be 55 which is the the first and Emma in
MMA to have the three title never been done before.
Or it could be maybe by that time it would be another guy maybe,
I don't know.
It would be someone will come back and do something great that w will be the man
to beat.
You know what I mean?
Right.
We talk about the Diaz brother and Alzheimer's.
I change,
shoved it subject a little bit,
but we on the same way,
it's sad for four and Nick Diaz that he doesn't fight because stylistically
people might think I'm crazy,
but stylistically I think he can beat Tyron Woodley.
I think he can.
He's that kind of guy.
I keep coming at to keep coming at you.
And Tay is good at taking shots that keep coming,
keep coming at you.
And I remember when I fought him.
It's terrifying because you got tired and this guy keeps coming at you and make
you feel like you claustrophobic and you,
you do things at him and he keep coming in and he's very nature and they're laid
around like after like three,
four rounds.
Fuck man is like,
it's very,
he never gets tired.
It doesn't get terrible.
[inaudible] it makes you,
it's exhausting.
So nervous on the nervous system and the mental system,
not only physically solo numb,
not much physically it's,
it's on the nervous system.
He'd come at you and you fake.
And then,
uh,
and,
and there was like a reaction time and recent time when you fight in all like,
like I studied this with my thing when I was fighting guys and Nate Diaz,
he make people tired.
He make the nick,
nick,
Nick.
That's why he wins fight.
He's kind of a slow Gabe up,
but people get more tired than him quickly,
especially in their nervous system.
There was a guy like Bj Penn for example,
when I fought Bj Penn,
I knew that Bj Penn at the best reaction time of all fire we have seen in UFC
when he was at his best.
I measure the guy,
we know what I mean for rest of merger with with the frame,
you know a frame,
like a picture.
When you throw a bunch of big click,
click,
Bj Penn at the best reaction time of all fighters be Bj Penn when he was in his
best.
When I fought him,
I knew if I go straight at him,
you have a better reaction time that then than me.
So my goal is he had a very good reaction time,
but a bad reset time.
So it was recent time is,
is,
is kind of a,
the endurance for the brain so he could react like a smell.
You could react very fast.
But after a while he got tired very,
very fast after a lot of faking it and then this,
I make him guests and stuff.
So it was getting very tired fast.
So because of that I could get him because of that equity.
I could fake it and make him tired and lower his reaction time and then get him
later.
Yeah.
So Nate Diaz us.
Why he's so good.
And they,
nick,
Nick's Yas.
Sorry.
That's what he's so good.
And then that sad for him and he can't,
he doesn't fight is fast.
Are his best years are now.
We should do now.
And that's why you should do man.
He needs only 33 is that what we said?
33 or 34 I mean he's in his Yay.
Should do it now.
He should do it.
The man he had done a port city make a lot money.
He could,
he could do it could,
you could do it.
They suspended him for pot after he fought Anderson Silva and then he had to pay
a fine.
They never paid the father because he's,
he's Nick Diaz is it now?
But I respect that because in his mind need,
think is wrong and he don't,
he has a line.
You have a code,
you know and the same thing.
I have the code for me for the drug test policy.
I didn't want to come back unless they do some,
I say it to Lorenzo and Dana after my fight,
my last fight I say it is that I my code and I it they wouldn't have done it.
I would not have come back.
I have never Hendricks was on something.
This is is that,
there's that question.
I don't have the evidence and we'll never have it.
Like you don't have the evidence and I we talk about fighters like I like that
got cut.
You don't have the evidence they were there before it got cut.
Like I not to have the evidence.
The only thing I can say is I didn't want to attack one particular individual
and I wanted to change the system because if you have one individual,
another one would come.
So in that particular case it was Hendrix and I want it to change it.
And in the beginning he agreed with me to do it,
but then he changed his mind and that's when I got very angry.
Agreed with you to take me.
I agreed.
I agreed that it was public.
He agreed.
When we say you can look,
you have the evidence that in the interview he said he agreed to do a test but
then he said,
ah no,
I did not agree.
Because also the UFC told him to not agri that UFC told him the UFC told him is
the truth.
They told him to not do it because they weren't,
they didn't want,
they had a problem maybe with the um,
the VAD Duh,
the Wa that Aveda world anti-doping that there is a wider that make the
guideline but there vadder that's Vander that I took.
They had a problem with them.
I don't know why.
Did he know he was Marimekko rep read something or it was a lady but they had a
problem so they said to not do with the test may not do it,
period.
I don't know if it was big.
I think it was because of weather because I made that little investigation on
that and I got very angry.
That's why like sickle logically I said to myself,
I shouldn't,
I should not have.
If I would have go back in time and I would not have that,
that fight I'm going to have to take,
that's fine.
That's why I respect a lot of fight or they stand up for themselves.
I didn't have the courage that I didn't do it when it was time to do it and I
should,
that I regret it about this one thing.
I regretted my career.
I should have done it as I don't want to sign.
Okay,
take your belt.
I'm going,
I should have done that before.
Maybe I would have come back earlier
so I would miss a paycheck,
but wouldn't who you know and I enough,
I would have enough.
You know what I mean?
So you don't want to say whether or not you suspect that Johnny Hendricks is
doing something,
but there was people that were definitely doing something.
Yes.
I don't have the evidence.
Maybe you did.
Maybe you don't want to accuse.
And I a lot of guide,
they do it and I don't,
I don't want to judge them because I love that they have a family to feed and
everything and this could make the difference between winning $1 million or not
winning and like,
Eh,
at all.
You know what I mean?
So everybody has a different reason why are they the,
they do it and I,
and it's just a system and courageous it to do with it has that problem.
Yeah.
And especially if there's no testing or the testing is very poor,
like the testing when you first started your career,
I mean basically just had to pee after the weigh in and you were okay.
You have to be,
even now,
it's still easy to,
to even now it's even so,
yeah,
man,
it is like how would someone rig,
okay,
let's say you have a,
we're about on my phone.
Okay.
You know,
I'm saying it then everybody knows that.
Especially that she thought,
I didn't know that look after I thought it true.
It's not 100% sure,
but let's say I want to have a,
an injection of a product that will last and my buddy for two days or one day.
So I know that particular day I cannot be tested because if I am,
I'm screwed.
Right?
So I put in a,
I put my tea and my worry about that I'm traveling to the Freakin Antarctica,
Antarctica or anywhere like somewhere that is crazy believable.
And then I come back and do two days after.
But that's obsessed with sin,
my buddy for a certain period of time.
But it will,
they effect of it will last maybe a month.
And now we talk about performance enhancing drugs.
Joe People don't misunderstand.
Is there all,
yeah,
but it still doesn't make different.
Yes,
it does make the difference.
And then athlete and the reason is in the 80s and before it w it was giving you
more power,
more stem in a Morin Germans now a man with the technology,
they have stuff that will change your reaction time,
your confidence,
your reset time and not,
this is a huge,
huge application man.
If you're,
if you're play baseball or union in finding,
you see the things coming,
you have your reaction time,
your sharper in dead brain.
What makes a guy athletic?
It's not as muscle.
The reason why you saying both is you run faster.
There's many reasons why.
But one of the main reason is because his brain,
his nervous system is better.
And if you make your nervous system better and more,
more competent,
a better,
you're a better athlete,
man,
you better fight or you better baseball player,
you better,
you better person a better person in a way.
Of course that effect is limited,
but there's still the,
the muscle memory thing that will last,
you know,
and he could laugh forever.
So now where that technology man at one point that sport,
that's why I'm afraid I'm afraid to sport becomes so messed up that with the
gene doping and all that,
I want point it would be off sport would be completely,
completely messed up in the future.
I talk not now,
but sport will be,
it won't be any normal people competing would be all like kind of a Seaborg
people cyborgs ever.
But people are really worried about gene doping and the [inaudible] are already
starting to do that.
But not any gene.
Even the mother,
the mother and stuff,
performance enhancing drug de Doo,
man.
It's very hard to catch up people.
So like I said,
it's easy to take something.
I mean,
there's always that chance that you get cut,
but that's how I,
if I would do it,
that's how I would do.
I would break down,
I'm going to Nark Antartica get an injection,
then I come back and I'm,
I'm good.
No.
Wicki told me that there are starting,
will they,
they have it and they don't
know whether or not people are taking it,
but they're taking,
testosterone's is derived from animals,
not from wild yams,
like the way they get testosterone now if you get like a testosterone injection,
they're getting it from a wild yams and some yams.
Yeah.
The fruit of the,
the,
you know,
the vegetable,
the tube or you know,
it's like in Jamaica is they,
they,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's how they're getting testosterone.
They're getting it from that
plant based,
um,
wild Yam testosterone.
But now,
uh,
they're able to get it from animals and the animal testosterone,
you,
you don't like,
they do carbon isotope tests and the carbon isotope test don't detect the
difference between a animal testosterone and human testosterone,
but there's a current tests.
One of the things that they do is they freeze your piss and they freeze your
blood for,
I think they're doing it for years,
and this is how they've caught some of these Russian wrestlers and they've taken
away gold medals from guys at one in the early two thousands for a,
they've found new tests,
and with the new test,
they'd be able to determine that they were taking several days.
That same thing when Ben Johnson beat Carl Lewis.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
And Ben Johnson this,
well,
he was on some shit,
but guess what,
Carl [inaudible] some shit.
Yeah.
Then I think nine out of 10 or eight out of that,
like the guy that that finished like eight,
like it was a Brazilian guy.
He would eat it.
Any enter,
you got interviews?
I'd,
yeah,
it was just aligned fillers for the main guy.
He would have won the gold medal.
Right.
Because the man,
that shit changed your life,
man,
that changed your life may make you a better living.
Million naira may be sponsorship that just so bad,
you know.
I see.
Yeah man,
this is crazy.
How about Lance Armstrong?
I mean when you go the Tour de France,
when he won and then they took his title away,
all the people that were below him,
we're also guilty.
So you'd take his title away.
What about the number two?
He's fucking guilty too.
Number three,
they said that on one of the years that he won,
you had to go back to 18th place to find a guy who's never caught taken anything
that's a dirty sport.
But man,
you asked me if I think he was taking,
I don't know.
I haven't asked suspicions have a suspicion,
but it's not right.
If you know what that would the evidence because Iq,
someone,
yes,
I agree with and even today it's,
if,
I think there was some guys,
there is a lot of guy that takes the red and performance enhancing drug.
Yes,
yes.
And I have an idea of who and I'm pretty like just for my gut feeling,
99.9% sure,
but I don't want to have the abundance.
It's not what you think.
Some way you know is what you can prove.
And I,
I don't know,
you know,
talking to,
I'm in that game,
I'm talking to a lot of people in between fighters.
We know who does,
who.
There's only a few and full of people with does the old,
the whole team.
Yeah they don't,
one guy could do these steam,
the steam,
these theme and one other guy can do two team.
The word guy that goes around them,
especially when you're,
you're top elite fighter got world goes I,
the word goes around,
you know like lady people,
they,
they talk to me and they say if I,
if I would be interested,
I'd been off different offered before in different things,
you know,
what have you been offered before?
I've been offered men too sometime to go train and then like some deals,
you know like good go train and do,
do,
do something.
Being being part of a,
you know,
like they have a,
they take sample of your blood,
they know what is missing.
Then they put the stuff that is missing.
Make Cube as I know as I rather stay in Montreal,
you know,
like I like I and I don't say much Montrell could I,
it could be a lot of cheater too,
right?
Like I that's the thing.
You accuse a gym of cheating.
You can actually was a gym of cheating because everybody is different.
You know,
there's people cheating everywhere now you can't say,
oh this,
these people are cheap now man,
they just doesn't work like that.
It works.
Every individual,
you know,
if you made the choice,
if you decide to go that path,
you have to be ready to face the consequences.
If you don't face a consequence Zirena your,
your competition years and maybe you'll face later after you're gone and you
retire for your carrier.
As I,
a lot of a lot of people I know is creating a lot.
Some of my friend,
they were bodybuilders now the seed seed there,
buddy are mess up man.
There are moans all messed up date.
They,
they,
they got bad problem.
I don't want to be like that,
you know?
I don't want to be like that.
I want to be happy,
you know?
I want to be healthy.
Yeah.
They tear the joint apart too.
That's like,
uh,
I had um,
Dorian Yates on the podcast.
He can't even do pushups now and Dorian Yates was Mister Olympia.
It was a fucking giant guy.
But all that,
everything just ripped apart.
It's like everything's all fucked up.
It just doesn't work right anymore.
However,
if you ask these people,
would you do it again?
Maybe they say,
yeah,
maybe it was worth it.
Maybe it was worth it.
Maybe it wasn't.
I think it depends on every individual.
You know what I mean?
But for me,
I'm happy with what I have so far.
I know I could get more,
maybe the future,
but I don't want to do to go that path to try to risk everything or what do you
want to think when testosterone replacement therapy was a thing and they were
allowing people like ve tour and these people who take testosterone,
how as so freaking angry about this?
I think it was like,
you know,
I everybody,
it's a different case for everybody,
but I believe if you,
if you need to take the medication to compete performance and medication to
compete,
you shouldn't be allowed.
Shouldn't be.
And,
and,
and Joe,
I'm not against steroids.
I'm going to explain it to like,
people say,
oh he's,
I guess I'm not against Purr like stay steroid or Tessa.
I'm not against it.
If it's for their wellbeing,
if it's an older man who we cannot have sex with his wife and he is like,
man,
that he goes to the doctor,
it's like,
man,
I,
I lose the edge at it a bit.
Can director was a yeah,
I put the cream that that will increase it.
That sounds so you and the guy is happier.
You have sex with his wife?
Competition?
Yes.
In terms of competition,
if me and you were fighting and I,
we sign that we're not using any weapon and I'm talking about biological weapon
and we'll fight men to men as real martial artists by a card of a code of honor
and you'll behind or me,
I go and inject myself something to make me stronger or more competent.
Might my could also help my neurone deferred to fire.
Better to get something to be more,
to be better,
to enhance my performance.
Now,
now I'm against that.
This is a code of honor and the the,
if you don't respect that code man,
it should be out of martial arts.
What are people taking that makes the reaction time better?
It makes her mind,
I don't know that that name,
but there there is many.
If you talk to a guy,
there's a lot of things,
a lot of things I know baseball player,
they take stuff for the reaction time,
like the picture because in baseball and tennis and even in fighting before you
throw a punch,
there is an indication you're,
but the body language,
he reads something like before you throw a ball,
there's a movement for you punched her as well.
So you see better you,
you brain,
there's even a medication you can take for exam.
You study in school,
there is an exam to you have an exam.
Tomorrow you're going to study or your your desk stuff that you need to know.
Then and night he will increase you.
Then you go pass the exam.
I know it some crazy go,
go,
go get it.
And it's crazy man.
Well,
I know Adderall,
Adderall Swan.
It makes you a man.
He make you better,
better in the brain.
If you make your brain better,
your nervous system better,
man.
You bet you you're a better fighter.
Yeah.
It's not only the physic,
physical,
[inaudible] uh,
enhancement.
It wasn't the 80s.
Now winning the 2000 year now.
Now it's neurologic man.
That's when it's crazy dangerous and so new.
It will be like it would the gene doping.
Forget it man.
The athlete will be born athlete.
You want me?
I got like me or anybody that fight in UFC won't be able to compete and you have
seen it anymore because they are not super humane human.
You know what I mean?
No,
I agree.
The future sport will be so messed up.
It will be crazy.
We're all going to be gamers.
Play video game.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
You're probably right.
We're all going to be gamers.
They're this,
this will be m this thing that like being an athlete,
will it?
It's not gonna make any sense in the future.
I believe in or maybe it will be completely ridiculous.
It's like,
oh,
you're not born.
You never going to be,
you have no choice.
You know what I mean?
And it will be real because you're not born to be an APP.
You're not bred to be an athlete.
Yeah.
They would with gene editing with their,
they're going to be able to change your height.
They're going,
they can do it now.
They can do it now.
They haven't really shown that they can do it with humans in America,
at least.
Crazy.
But there are absolutely experiencing are experimenting with it all over the
world,
the cow and every like.
It's insane.
They're doing a lot of crazy shit.
Yeah,
and I think maybe it's a hundred years,
maybe it's 50 years,
but whatever it is in that amount of you're going to be dealing with people that
are basically superheroes.
Yeah.
Sport will be destroyed.
That's what when,
when that APP in sport it will be destroyed.
Yeah.
No,
I agree with sport will be finish the hundred meter.
Can you believe like how fricking fast a human being can be to be closer to the
zero second yeah.
Do you think we'll pass the bar of nine second one day?
It's tear are radically not impossible in a way.
Like,
I mean I won't point there.
There's a line that you can't,
you can't diminish that time,
but it's like a,
a charter of Zuno like you can't,
you know.
But if we got that sort of performance and ensuing drug decks would be,
but there'll probably be some sort of a side effect to it and some sort of a
downside to it.
You know,
they'd probably die younger or their tissue will diminish faster.
But who knows,
maybe they'll be able to regenerate stuff if,
if you talk to some doctor that knows,
I know you have done,
they said that steroid leg it performance enhancing drug if you do it,
if they do it well,
it's okay.
Some people don't have any side effects of it.
Right.
They don't abuse it.
Yes.
Yeah.
So man,
maybe it won't have any side effect.
Maybe everybody will be on it.
Maybe it will be like a,
like a iPhone will be like,
oh,
that's like,
who knows,
who knows the future,
who knows?
You know,
that's totally possible.
I mean we,
you might be in a lot of ways,
one of the last of the natural athletes.
Maybe.
Maybe it's a few more years before we get there,
but yeah,
man,
when I think about it,
this is going to be,
it's going to be finished.
It's going to be,
I don't know,
maybe we'll going to be video game players or whatever.
When you see yourself competing again,
how much longer do you think you'll wait out?
I mean,
you're 37 now.
When do you think you'll will be healthy enough?
When will your colitis feel good enough?
Like do you have a time period to say maybe a few weeks.
Maybe take a few weeks,
maybe
one to three month Max.
Maybe maximum.
Maybe I'd be less than that.
Maybe less than that.
A little bit of time off.
Just a little bit.
Yeah.
I want to make sure I get past that because I feel like if I go back into it and
I,
and it will start all over again.
I don't want that.
It was bad Jew.
I couldn't like,
I couldn't sleep night [inaudible] crap.
Like bad crap neg.
I stay up all night and add the sparing the next day and he,
oh my God.
It was crazy,
man.
It was very bad.
He had blood.
I had to go in the bachelor,
add blood,
man,
you feel like you,
you want to go to the bathroom.
I then in,
I think [inaudible] is the blood,
the blood that come on man,
that you could look at the bathroom and you see the blood.
You think it's like,
man,
what's wrong?
You think get like them,
the dream Catcher to movie with eh?
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like it's like,
what the hell?
You know what I mean?
It's crazy,
man.
You're,
you're like,
what's happening with me?
Am I dying?
His eye is,
it was very,
it was very well read.
I don't want to go back to this.
I want to make sure I,
I think Cara,
this stuff and so just maybe even a few more months of just taking care of your
body.
Mont Week,
week,
I want,
I want to see when I felt good,
I I lethal.
I let a little bit time when I felt like 100% like I don't feel anything like
some Thai Seville.
I when I going to eat,
I felt,
I felt not that grant,
not that pain,
but I,
I feel inside is something different,
but it's diminish every,
every week it's every month it diminished.
I see a difference.
So if you do go back and you'd go back to 55 have you tried to make that cut
before?
I never tried and I won't.
I'm going to explain it to you.
I'm not a fan of weight cutting.
I think weight cutting should be
like a marathon runner,
a marathon runner.
When you train for my right on.
He never does a marathon in this training.
He does af or maybe a quarter of it,
the different things.
So it's not lt to lose your weight.
You dehydrate yourself and starving is not that bad.
But it is more than the hydrating dry duration problem.
Yeah.
I'm very worried about lt issue and I don't want this very important.
So when I do it,
I go all in.
I'll do like the Bisping fight.
I never tried to do to get my weight much.
It's different and you don't when you go up and go down.
But
I said yes,
I do it.
And I go and I,
you know what I mean?
And I do it.
Do you like that trail of it?
The excitement of the unknown kind of excite me in a way.
I don't know if you know,
so it's kind of an experimentation.
It's live.
I cannot messed up.
That's what excite me.
It's not the,
Oh,
I know I can't.
No,
I don't know man.
I'm going to do it now.
It's happening now.
That's,
that's what excite me.
Well this guy's a year,
so I was like,
Kevin Lee's your size.
You know,
he'd given me is about my size.
I think a Guy Gabby is about,
I think close to 200 I saw a 24 Ferguson,
is that you?
He was I posting picture.
He was 200 I never been naturally 200 like when I fought best thing at one point
I was almost 200 like I was like big guy at like,
but I was like all like water retention and I didn't feel,
I didn't feel right.
It was not feeling good man.
Kevin is a big guy and there was an article today I saw somewhere there was
saying,
you know the Kevin really wants a water and 65 pound weight loss.
Like you can't really make one 55 very much longer.
I think it would be the best man.
This guy,
I think if I look all the new guy that are coming,
it's freaking scary,
man.
I'm 37 maybe I have one or maybe two maybe three I don't know.
When I do my thing and I get out of there,
when do you think you're going to retire?
Do you have an idea?
Oh,
I never got a 40 you've,
it's impossible that I fight pass 40 I'll be impossible.
I'm not going to fight in a cage at four years old and it's like 37 demand is
that you feel a kid that played like that's our nurse wasn't a girl.
What he says to me is like I could that play with a train.
He's two years old,
three years old,
four years old,
five years old.
Then you look at the train when you get six years old and like the hell I'm
doing with that train at 40 years old is Spanish for me fighting in the cage.
I've done it.
It's not interesting or,
and I'm 40 years old.
I am,
I'm a,
I'm a grown man.
I'm not going to fight in a freaking cage at 40 years old.
Only 36 months from now.
You're saying you're saying it like it's forever.
Yeah,
exactly.
So it has to happen fast.
It has to happen fast and if it don't happen,
I might be,
I might be doing well.
The comeback alone will select one of the greatest comebacks ever to come back
after four years when the title beat the champion and beat him definitive
definitively rear naked choke,
put him to sleep.
That's why I drew it need to be something that really excite me.
Begin.
I'm going to tell you something.
One of my friends,
CT Fletcher,
he says something also CT Fletcher,
just that as a heart transplant and he's going good now.
He said,
I love to CT CT,
you're at the inspiration man.
See d your inspiration man.
I love that guy.
He says sets his faction.
Is that Dev Dev blue and it's true.
Now I'm happy,
I'm satisfied.
But if I see something on satisfaction as what was he says deaf.
Blue is finish.
If you're satisfied,
if you're a champion and you satisfy your retirement because you're going down,
you finish going to get hurt.
As an athlete,
especially in game not and everything I do,
I go further and further.
That's why I didn't want this fight Nate Diaz.
Cause I've,
I fight Nate Diaz.
If it's been done before,
it's been,
it's not excite.
Excite that for me and I would be going into that fight,
satisfy and if I could do that,
I'm going to,
it's very dangerous.
I want to do something that I'm like,
like the one 55 I'm like,
I never did it before.
Title or beating a certain guy that ease on that freak and the rise and beat
them because ebay already beaten Connor.
Go be be.
It could be.
I don't know if they're new guy that do something that is unbeatable and may I
come back,
I'm like,
oh George never going to be that.
It may just say never man.
I love it.
They say never when they are not as as it is.
And when he said never going to come back am I could excite me.
And when you say I cannot do that,
it's never been done before.
That's mean.
If I do it,
it would be the first time that excited me.
That really turned me on as,
but there's a lot of things that turned me on in life is,
is a woman dinosaurs and this,
the people that say,
you don't,
I don't that really going crazy.
Dinosaurs body ontologies is up.
Can I really love?
Wow.
That's awesome.
I traveled the world during those four years off,
by the way,
that,
did you?
Yeah.
Did you do during those four years off?
I was,
I trouble a lot of the world on the site.
On a sightseeing.
Yeah.
I W I wouldn't ever be that.
That made me realize too that I could never be a paleontologist.
I don't have the patience to go like a toothbrush for hours.
I like to get the knowledge of it to be on the field,
to get the knowledge fast,
but I don't like to work together.
Not as dry,
which make me not that real cardiologists.
They find out that they're just as willing put the work into it.
Yeah.
In MMA,
I'm willing to pour the work into it to become the champion,
you know,
but then pan out.
That's how I,
I,
because I want point.
I thought I liked both equally.
Now I realize,
no,
I like the sport better.
Album of the sport of MMA is so exciting and paleontology is probably very
exciting once you find like a t rex head or something like that.
Is that knowledge?
The knowledge is exciting.
I mean I have a thing in every month.
Every time they have a discoveries,
it's in my phone.
Oh,
APP.
Yes.
Every time is a new discovery or something like boom.
And my friend that make fun of me,
they're like,
then you fight it a cage.
You beat up people.
Why didn't you like paleontology was real.
We do
cause they make fun of me.
I went in Argentina,
in them,
in a Patagonia.
I was there too with uh,
patio,
Telogis,
bio biologists and uh,
and and microbiologists to four have an on site,
you know.
And I had that blast,
man,
it was amazing.
But people is,
I,
Georges is gone and that Freakin bad land and buy like I loan is a laden for the
rest of the world too,
to do that kind of stuff.
But you know,
so they were making fun.
Did you find anything?
I did not find it,
but I went on site.
I saw eggs.
I saw a sauropod remains tight dinosaurs.
They're there.
These are the still in the ground when you were there,
like they're fine eating it.
Yeah,
but Julie thinks it's a long process,
man.
Yeah,
it does that mean that as been covered for at least like 66 million years,
man.
You talk about light and the place where I was,
it was,
it was a early cretaceous.
I know it was eight grade they should have,
but it was like a hundred million years.
So that's mean.
It did not get exposed to oxygen for a hundred million years.
That's where you get,
so you,
it's like a crime scene man.
Where go into these thing.
It's Frickin there,
man.
It's like a crime scene that you discover,
but like I like a hundred million years quite seen man.
You see these soul rapids robots,
these dinosaurs.
It's insane,
man.
What's crazy too,
that it's not even really a bone anymore.
The mineral has replaced the bone and you just get the shape of the bone that's
sort of been fossilized.
Yeah.
That's why if you see like mega don teeth,
they're black and milds that Miguel is crazy.
It's insane.
Man May got it done just like the strongest bite.
Fourth ever recorded,
man.
It's crazy.
It's a big fucking animal.
It was a huge fish.
Yeah,
just shoot it.
Feed on wells like it's crazy.
But I,
this is one of the things that I really excited me,
so during those four years I was doing,
man,
I had to add a blast.
I didn't have that time to do it before that and I felt like it was missing in
my life.
Really?
Paleontology man.
Yeah.
That's fascinating.
I went down to Alberta.
I went all swing the in m and a that quota and United States that want to go in
Egypt and Egypt and Morocco.
There was some site that they were once upon a time.
He was like,
like I'm talking about this,
probably be,
nobody cares,
but I,
I love it.
They were like treat giant,
giant Apex Burnett's or living in the same,
uh,
like a giant crocodile sarco,
sue sushis,
Karch,
Armando,
Zuora and a spinal sores.
These two live in the same area and wonder what happened like Tree Alpha
freaking Predator if we're living in at the same time.
And I wonder if they interact with each other and it would,
it must have been a crazy time man.
I have a friend and one of his good friends has a ranch in Montana and uh,
he found something on the ranch and he called this a paleontologist and they
went to his ranch and they shut the place down.
Like,
dude,
you got a t rex here.
Really?
Yeah.
They gave him over a million dollars for it.
And they escalated this t rex and his,
his ranch.
And apparently it was a really good specimen.
Can either,
if you find something,
it's part of it,
it belongs to the government.
Let's say.
Let's say,
let's say you find a bone in your backyard.
It doesn't belong to you.
Can you believe it locked up?
Yeah.
That's sack van.
This is very bad.
Americans.
Got You guys beat for that?
When I was young Joe,
I remember I used to live in countryside.
I used to go with it,
try to go with find bones,
but I didn't know back then I was not educated as I thought.
Maybe I could find dynasts I was spending hours and finding,
trying to find dinosaur that everywhere,
like I took,
I thought it was a dinosaur.
I used to bring it back.
Am I?
My mom is a,
yeah,
it's a dyno.
Sorry.
I stayed,
yeah,
right there because it was kind of a triangular shape.
But then I found out that all of that place where I come from,
it was all erosion.
So there is nothing from Cretaceous or Jurassic Triassic backdate.
It's all like before that.
So it's all gone.
So it's just crazy,
man.
It has been a long time.
I was in Montana once and the,
there's this area that used to be the great western inland sea and this,
uh,
this area,
like the ground is like this mucky ground,
especially when it rains,
it's essentially silt,
like the bottom of a lake,
you know?
That's because it was a,
it was like a seat in between saying cutting the,
I met the,
the cutting and the America in Af.
Yeah.
And so last year and lateral media to conduct,
you know,
all about that.
Knowing this man,
I know as much as I met me with this daily almost.
Yeah.
Wow.
Maybe not,
but I am passionate with this man a long time.
It's fascinating when you're walking around this area in Montana,
it's called the Missouri breaks and uh,
because this,
uh,
this ground,
it does feel like,
you know,
if you've ever like seen a lake bed,
if the water recedes,
it's got that silty sort of weird mud.
This is all,
the whole ground is like this.
It sticks to your boots.
Like it,
it gets heavy and comps on the bottom of your boots.
Like this muck,
maybe it,
man,
we don't know what the future would look like,
man.
Eh,
sometime I'm thinking too,
I'm like,
you know what?
People talk about the environment and they say,
oh,
the pollution will make,
we have hot hair,
an ice age hot here.
It's been going forever.
But what I'm thinking,
I'm like,
yeah,
okay.
Of course the pollution and the human as an effect on the climate,
the climate.
But I wonder how much of the,
um,
how big we have an ethic.
Some people say is it's debatable,
is it,
is it that big or is not that big?
Some some sizes,
yes,
it is bad.
Some says,
yeah,
it's bad ways.
We don't have that much of an effect.
As you know,
we,
I don't know about that.
I would like to have a clear answer to two to four days.
I think.
I think we have an effect,
but I like,
I wonder how now we're going into a hot here.
The glacier or for our,
our are melting,
but the hot hair,
we'll uh,
we'll,
we'll go to a,
an ice age,
you know that,
right?
Because of the current and everything.
So I wonder how,
you know,
how much of an effect and how long it'll take.
You know,
because we don't have any record,
recent record of all long.
Everything takes,
we know a little bit,
but not that much.
You know,
it's a fascinating subject.
Yeah,
man,
it would be,
are we going to live through that time?
Probably not,
but I'm leaving.
You know what I mean?
It's like how long it will take.
I'm very interesting about that.
That's why I love the,
these things.
Learning from that past make you understand something,
the present and in the future I may I think is really interesting.
Yeah,
no I'm,
I'm very fascinated by it.
Are you still interested in aliens that's demand this deal?
So that's the thing.
When I first came on your show,
yeah,
you cut me really off guard because Bruno's most,
most people that we talk about aliens,
they completely think you're crazy or you're disregards I,
Yah you got to talk about like,
you know they,
they,
most people that I attract with their,
you know,
they,
so you feel like ridicules then I,
and then after I find out you read a lot about that stuff,
like the Sumerian texts,
the creation tablets like a rescission and all that stuff.
And I do too.
I mean,
I don't know if there is,
if there is early on that like I think they would be life form.
I don't.
If it's intelligence,
we don't have evidence for it and I think,
or ego as human being want us to believe that the alien came and interact with
us.
That's our ego.
But if they're that far advanced from us and they come from a different,
well maybe they don't want to interact because we have nothing to offer them.
They're not going to conduct a farmer and ask him what kind of suspension is
wearing.
You know what I mean?
Like they,
they don't get,
you know what I mean?
But think about what you just said about paleontology.
I mean we're paying attention to the stupid fucking lizards that lived 65
million years ago.
It's true.
I mean,
don't you think there would be curious to this weird monkey with nuclear
weapons?
Yeah,
but we don't communicate with it.
We don't take direct.
We observe.
There's ways that you can learn from us without communicate.
I don't know.
I mean it's,
I think it's our ego that make us,
we want to feel special.
We want to feel that
like,
oh,
we were different,
you know,
like we were different beans then.
For example,
a Doug or,
yeah,
we can think because we're smart,
but like,
I dunno,
how would this have been giving,
giving to a cycad oh no.
You know,
and I,
and you were talking about it like when I was young,
I used to have uh,
like you talk about the last time you said,
ah,
you,
you were talking about like the experience.
I said I remembered that I remembered but I can't recall it when I was,
when I was young ad I don't if it's a dream,
I remember I used to dry,
I used to draw a figure of bud store.
I say my mom is a,
is the amount sir.
They come get me at night.
That I was,
that's why I,
that that's what we talked last time.
I was very uncomfortable and I didn't want to talk about it because I was like,
man,
how the hell do you nosy,
you know,
everything man,
this guy,
he knows everything.
He may research and stuff.
So I,
I'm,
I made,
I made the drawing and,
and uh,
then my,
my mom,
even though today I said,
hey,
I want to,
I want to see the drawing,
you know,
like I,
and I,
and I showed the drawing and I'm like,
and then I,
then after,
I remember later I rem,
I remember that.
I remember,
but I couldn't remember.
You understand what I mean?
I remembered that I remembered that something that happened,
but now I can't remember what exactly happened.
Could be a nightmare.
It could be another slip,
sleep paralysis or paralysis in my imagination.
I don't have evidence,
you know what I mean?
And that's what we talk about it last time.
And,
uh,
that's,
that's what happened to me.
And,
and,
and I hope,
I hope,
I hope it's nightmare.
It's a nightmare.
You know what I mean?
But the thing is,
later on I saw some documentary on TV.
I saw some people that had a similar experience as me,
loss of memory and things like this when they were young and they claimed day,
they get a,
they get to hypnosis and stuff.
Then they,
they,
they go back and time and they explained to get an abducted by Alan.
Then I start to freak out about it because I,
I send them.
Is it that what happened to me and then I,
but there was more,
a lot more logical explanation,
you know what I mean?
But that's why when you brought that back,
I freaked out.
I was like,
oh,
daddy knows this.
Like how the hell he knows this.
I,
I didn't want to talk about it.
But then he,
then it was also,
my agent was there.
He was like,
Hey,
we need it in 10 minutes.
I'm going,
I,
I didn't,
we were misinformed.
We didn't know what that podcast was.
I that long in this,
out of the high,
all of these things in my head,
I baby,
we've been,
I didn't know what to make of it,
you know?
So that,
that's what it was.
Yeah.
It's entirely possible that we're experiencing something when we're dreaming
that were angry,
sleeping well,
maybe unconscious,
that maybe there's dimensions that consciousness travels too that are
nonphysical that like this,
this dimension,
what we're in right now.
We could touch this table,
move this microphone around.
These are physical dimensions,
but it's entirely possible that whatever your spirit is or your consciousness or
your,
your mind,
when,
when you're thinking of your thoughts
and your soul that you say you're,
you said you're a soul.
Yeah.
Whatever that means you believe is this is a soul.
You believe.
You don't know what that means.
It's a weird word,
right?
It's a real,
it has religious connotations,
but,
but the,
the idea of whatever your essence is as a human being,
there's,
there's something inside of all of us that makes us conscious and aware and,
and there and then that something is not there when you're sleeping.
And so is it dormant?
Is it just recovering,
which is,
you know,
the scientific version of it?
Or is it possible that while you're in this dream state in your body shuts off,
that your mind and your consciousness travels to a nonphysical dimension that
you can only access through the chemicals that are released in your brain,
which we know produce psychedelic experiences.
So if you took the chemicals that are released during your brain or inside your
brain,
like dimethyl trip to me and,
and uh,
there,
there's all sorts of different psychedelic chemicals that are produced by the
mind.
If you take these outside of,
you know,
the dream state,
if you take these drugs,
you have these crazy,
fantastic experiences and we know these are produced by the brain.
They produce,
they produced by the brain.
Now they're produced by the brain,
then produced by the liver and the lungs.
We believe they're produced by your third eye,
which is your pineal gland.
They've shown the cottonwood research foundation has shown that this,
this is done in rats.
The rats produced dimethyltryptamine in their pineal gland.
It doesn't necessarily mean that people do,
but it's logical to imply that people probably,
or conclude the people probably do it as well.
So those,
those chemicals that are producing these psychedelic experiences are being
released by the brain.
But we don't know why.
And we don't know what they're doing.
Well wait,
when,
when you sleep that guy,
that guy at Metro Walker,
yes.
It was amazing.
Right?
When you sleep,
you're,
you're a guardian.
You're logic is not there.
That part of your brain.
Yeah.
So we could,
that's probably the most Ajay called exper experience,
but it's,
it's kind of a freaking scary thought of thinking that man is like,
it makes me wonder sometime sometime you at night that you're at night that loan
and you were thinking then,
I mean I'm my guide,
I think I left,
you know,
I'm thinking about all kinds of scenario.
Like in a fight I fight.
Think about a all of a sudden,
oh by the knife.
On the same way you thinking,
what if this happened for real?
Or what if like,
man,
it's sick care.
We talk,
man.
It's,
it's,
it's a,
it's just nothing more scary in the world.
Well,
what is scarier?
Is it scary to think that when you die you're just gone and nothing happens?
Or is it scary to think that your consciousness leaves this physical dimension
and goes into what's essentially a well of souls?
Just a dimension,
a nonphysical dimension of consciousness.
We're all consciousness interacts with each other and it's just geometric
patterns that don't have a,
a physical being attached to them.
It's,
it's,
it's hard for me to believe the consciousness is not material material.
Cause that's how you would say sometime people have,
they say,
oh he's a good person,
is a bad person.
I don't believe there is good and bad person.
I believe there is no people,
no baby born good or bad,
I believe is your environment and that makes that shape you.
And it has a lot to do with it.
[inaudible] have a lot to do.
And when you say they the mine,
let's say I'm a surfer,
I'm a person,
I'm a certain way,
you know me and as a certain way and it happened to me.
I know I have a friend that happened to him.
It was my best friend and he,
and he's dead now.
Unfortunately the Di,
it was a certain way,
but he got a car accident.
I remember after his car accident,
he changed man.
He was not that same guy.
He become a little bit paranoid.
Yes,
I've kind of dementia.
Yeah.
So the person I knew
was kind of dead.
Yeah,
but it was physically Ed,
the DNA,
everything was the same.
But is this,
the person is different.
Right.
So when you say it,
the soul,
the mind,
if we'd be really not material lake,
my materialistic,
that would not have changed.
But his personality was completely different.
See,
he had a short temper.
I remember he had a girlfriend,
was extremely jealous.
He was starting to beat her and stuff.
It was completely different.
Completely different person that you knew before.
So if they say it,
the mine,
your brain,
your brain is materialism,
but your mind is not.
So if you have it,
if you'd be,
if you have like if you have an accident like my friend and me,
but you have some sort of dementia or something that's mean.
If it's not materialism,
it would not happen.
It's possible,
but it's hard to say and you have the explanation that are like,
oh,
subjective and objective.
If I pinch you,
you say I'm a hurt.
There is no objective way to for me to to tell you that you really hurt because
even if I go away,
I'll open your brain.
I can't see it,
but you know the only way I know it's because of my experience,
but it can't prove it.
Right.
It's a fucking who knows.
Who knows.
It also
possible that when you think of consciousness or the soul or the what's going on
in the mind that is,
it's expressed through the body and then with the body is damaged,
that consciousness is damaged as well because your consciousness is now being
expressed through a lack of certain hormones.
Your,
your,
your mind itself.
The very brain might be an antenna or a something that uses consciousness in
order to move through life,
but that consciousness is independent from the brain and that the brain being
damaged.
It's just expressing consciousness in a fucked up way because you've got
dementia or Parkinson's or what other neurological disorders that people have.
But at the center of it,
it's still the same thing.
It's one of the things that people say when they have,
let's say you die,
you finish,
and then the best out of you will,
you mean we're still exists somewhere or somewhere in that of you,
but you independent of the body,
and this is just theories.
There's,
there are people that believe that consciousness is nonlocal and that the body
actually is just like an antenna for your consciousness.
Now,
if the body is damaged,
if your hormonal balance is all fucked up,
your neurological system is out of whack.
You like,
one of the things that Muhammad Ali said,
uh,
when they were talking to him about his Parkinson's is that he's still in there.
He just can't express himself because his body had been damaged by so many
fights,
so many hard sparring sessions and so many blows to the head that he wasn't
capable of expressing himself.
But inside he was still the same guy but he was trapped.
His consciousness was trapped in a broken body.
I see.
It's like that like a prison,
like a locomotion system and you know when you think about CTE,
like a lot of these football players like you know that Aaron Hernandez guy that
was a murderer and he was a football player and they examine his brain after he
was dead and like this is one of the worst cases of CTE we've ever seen after he
killed himself in prison,
they examined him and the the idea is that your consciousness is supposed to be
expressing itself through a healthy brain,
right through healthy hormones and healthy endocrine system,
a healthy neurological system and that in that way your,
your brain can,
your consciousness can express itself and do so without any physical hindrances.
Then there's also psychological,
what is lt?
I wise age,
but what age are you at the,
at the moment you start breeding and living,
there's some sort of change that occurred in your so,
sure.
Yeah.
What is that Lt State?
That's 1512 one years old at an then,
right.
One years old.
You're not that same person at 15 and 15.
You're not that same as 30.
I think it's pretty or not.
That's same.
My 60 I think they're not,
there's no independence.
I think they're all connected.
And I think that,
you know,
the,
the physical vitality of the body is important.
The vitality of the mines important.
But I think there's probably something,
you know,
when the first time I saw a real dead body,
like up close was,
uh,
my grandfather,
my grandfather died and uh,
you know,
went to the funeral,
they had an open casket.
It's very strange.
But one thing that I realized when I was standing there,
I'm like,
he's not even there.
He's not here.
Like,
he's not here.
It's this body.
I mean,
this might have been where my grandfather lived.
He might've lived in this body,
but he's not here anymore.
It was a very strange feeling to me because it was like internally I realized
something.
I get the fact that he's dead and he's not moving his body and he's been
embalmed and they put makeup on you and all this weird shit,
but it was also this feeling like he's not there.
He's gone.
Yeah.
You know?
What is it?
The body then is the body of vehicle for whatever
you are.
Yeah.
Maybe one day we'll know my,
maybe we won't.
It's very,
it's a really,
it's one of those questions.
It's conceptual.
It's also,
you know,
people have their ideological reasons for believing one thing or another.
There's people that are nihilist and think,
you know,
it's over when it's over and then you go to black and that's it.
You're done.
End of story.
Nothing happens when you're dead,
but you don't know that because you're never die.
We can't know.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a real,
it's a real open ended questions.
I'm on that same page as you.
If I do this,
I,
I do not know.
I a lot of idea has been presented to me.
A lot of the idea,
I reject it because it didn't make sense to me logically,
like descent,
like all day.
Do you believe in free will?
Right.
That's a good one.
If my phone is there and it falls,
there's a reason why it follows the SME tree of the phone,
make it fall.
Maybe I,
I blew me is a reason I want to say my phone on the fail.
But if you,
if you do something wrong,
for example,
you kill someone,
you just
decided like kill someone.
Like there's a reason why you do something and if you go back,
the reason there's a reason of,
the reason,
it's like,
it's like a dumb,
you know?
Yup.
I'm thinking,
I'm like,
man,
it made me think like,
I have no choice.
Right.
I gala,
you're world champion or your work for you.
I said,
yeah,
but I have no choice.
Well,
so I have no,
no.
Uh,
I don't deserve any props because I had no choice.
Right.
You are the product of your life experience.
To me.
That's what makes the most sense for me.
People think I'm crazy,
but I have an argument with a lot sometimes like a lot of really just people,
they say,
Oh yeah,
but I,
that's why I believe,
I believe sometime like,
and it doesn't mean I don't believe in God or I don't,
it doesn't mean that I am different.
I get my buddy,
but I believe have no choice.
If I do something,
I have no choice.
But you do have ethics and you do have morals and you do make decisions.
So that's where it gets slippery.
I don't think I made the decision.
No,
I didn't.
They,
they,
it was a cause to that decision.
There was a cost to everything.
And by definition there is a cause there was no free will.
Well,
it's a good argument.
I've heard it.
I mean,
Sam Harris argued it to me the best and made me really reconsider.
And uh,
Robert Sapolsky,
who was a,
a,
a famous scientist and deals with a lot of the functions of the human brain in
terms of like our motivations for things.
He's his take.
Was that in the future that will be,
you know,
when we look back today at like people that burn people for witchcraft and stuff
like that and how foolish they are,
he thinks we will have the same reaction to people judging and punishing people
based on their behaviors.
I agree 100% wow.
The just look go back and time in the back in the,
I think it's an ancient Greek there that man,
they were good teaching knowledge to kids in exchange of sexual favor.
There wasn't,
you know,
it happens.
Yeah.
Now we call it that Pinto Philly.
It's,
it's a,
it's,
it's wrong.
We put the people in prison,
but back in the day was normal.
You know what I mean?
Sometimes our conception of good and bad or,
or choice,
you know,
I choose like I don't,
I don't know man.
I don't believe there is good and bad.
I don't believe they choice.
I don't,
I don't and I have a hard time to believe I choose something.
Well,
there's certainly things that you,
my finger more positive than negative.
Right?
Like to my mind,
to people and friendly to people's more positive than being,
you know a murderer.
Yeah.
That's how you have a gun.
Let's say you want to kill someone and say,
Hey George,
can you borrow me a gun please?
As I,
Oh yeah,
I'm nice.
A nice gesture.
I will give you a gun,
but then you go kill someone.
So it's my gesture is nice or not nice.
It all good,
bad.
They'd all they fan of all you see Joe is all their banner values.
Depends on why you're giving the person the gun.
Right?
Oh Hey,
this guy raped a little kid.
Give me your gun.
I'm going to go kill him.
So like,
oh yeah,
I'll go do a good thing and I'll let you borrow my guns.
You can go kill this bad.
Okay.
Then my argument is,
okay,
you want to go,
you said,
George,
give me your gun.
I want to go kill this guy.
I said,
okay,
I go give you that gun.
This guy is Adele fiddler.
You go kill him as good thing or bad thing to certain proposed would be good.
So sort of people would be bad.
It depends what's good.
Bad.
Yeah.
Aside some time and thinking,
I was like,
man,
all of this we,
who knows?
And I know we don't.
We freaking don't know man.
I know.
That's the interesting thing about life is that there's a lot of things in life
that are messy.
There's not,
there's not a simple answer.
Yeah.
So we have choices.
It is,
it's like a pool game.
Yeah.
If mathematically I can,
like I,
I thought at this talk with Faris and Perez,
he's very smart,
he studied philosophy degree in philosophy.
It's like fighting,
you fight a guy,
you study a spatter and you know like when you do this,
you do that when you do this and do that.
So if you do this,
you think he will do that.
But maybe you won't because the environment has changed since then.
But you,
you know,
it's same thing.
So wait,
you play pool.
If I can measure the,
the,
the strength that I hit,
the ball ricocheted,
uncertain ball.
If I can measure everything precisely,
I will know where all the balls are ending up on the table.
You agree with that?
If I know the all the data of the universe and I boom,
I can predict do I up with that.
It would be the same thing with you.
If I know you by heart,
I know your genetic background.
I know all the data of the university and it's impossible to them.
If I wouldn't know,
I will know specifically what would you do exactly right now if I do that,
you will know.
You know what I mean?
How you would exactly react or what you about to say to me.
Yeah,
it's impossible.
So that's why.
That's why I don't believe in it.
That's why I believe I don't believe in free will.
I believe it's all it could be measurable if we don't.
It's impossible to measure.
Right?
And then when you see people that are doing good things and achieving good
things,
it motivates you to do good things and achieve thing and that also changes all
the people around you and makes them move in a certain direction as well.
And if you look at certain cultures that are extremely negative and Crime
Britain and fucked up,
they produce extremely negative crime,
fucked up people.
It's like there's,
there's all this going on there.
Is it the fault of those people?
And that's one of the things that people really criticized and I think rightly
so about like hardcore right wing people that think everyone should be
responsible for their own actions.
I don't care if you grow up at a crime Britain neighborhood,
you stop doing crime and you be a good person and that's not an easy task.
That brain has no way to know if a,
if an information is relevant or not.
If you grew up in the,
in the
Democrat system with democratic value,
you'll be,
if you're a smart,
you'd be as smart or Democrat.
If you grew up in this same but then the Republicans and we will be smarter
Republican.
However,
maybe there is things in your environment that would make you switch.
You know,
we don't eat your dad.
You're like,
fuck him,
I'm going to be a democrat.
We don't know.
But that your brain has no way.
So sometimes there's a show on TV,
like evil genius,
the guy a he outcomes.
He's so smart,
but he's a,
he's a naval [inaudible] that's,
this comes to what we talk about it.
Good,
bad.
There's no good bad.
There is no,
that's why when I fight,
I fight the guys like nick,
Nick,
Nick Diaz,
or if I,
and I swear it's true.
That's sad.
Drive my car and I see as a problem with the scarman I would stop to help him.
Yeah.
Give him too,
he was not nice or w w whoever it is,
I will do it because for me it's,
I don't think,
you know,
it's not that I'm nice.
Is that the way I think you know that it's who you are.
Yeah,
they are.
Exactly.
I have no choice to be at like I am.
It is what it is.
You know?
I've gotten better at that as I've gotten older,
a better at forgiving people and not holding grudges and not being upset at
people.
And if I see someone that I had a problem with in the past,
just give him a hug.
You know,
I don't,
I don't care.
Yeah.
I think it's,
it's,
it's not healthy to carry around grudges and it make you feel good.
Sometimes it feels real good and it feels real bad to keep that hate and anger
inside of you.
It festers away and you think of,
well,
if he says this down,
I'm going to say that.
Fuck him and he shouldn't have done this.
Well,
I shouldn't have done that.
But yeah,
but I only did that because he did this and you play,
you have these little stupid arguments in your head.
Instead of just saying hi and just being friendly or saying you're sorry or
saying,
hey man,
I don't,
I don't have a problem with you.
And there was a guy that,
um,
a few years ago I,
I drove my car on the,
on the street and Montreal.
He's second in the evening.
I say,
I told the guy coming at me and he asked for you bake for money,
put down my window.
This guy swears it's true story.
He's the guy that used to bully me in school.
Well,
I say,
I don't want to say his name and I say,
Hey,
wait a second,
I parked my name,
I had parked my car,
parked the car,
go talk to him is,
is it,
what the hell you doing here man z
and the,
and he thought that would be angry because then when he see me,
he saw his record like I shoot like no,
I'm world champion.
You know,
like I,
I can't beat the beat them up.
You know,
back in the day was like two years older than me was bigger.
It was beating me up in the bus.
This guy,
now we see me as I kind of a scare.
I get out of my car,
you don't know what,
you don't know if he should run or not.
So I go to MSA and said,
what'd you do hair man?
Zach is like,
you're,
it's like,
yeah,
I know,
but things doesn't go well for me,
you know?
I'm like,
I was like,
all right.
As I was like,
man,
you're a tall guy.
You're good looking and like what you're doing here man.
It's like I give him what I have left on me.
You know,
like I don't remember like I got a hundred something or I give him,
I said,
get Outta here man.
It's,
I get your full of potential is a get outta here man.
When I was young and when I want it to be like you,
you're a tall guy,
man,
you,
you're good looking.
It's like full of potential.
So he take his,
I was like,
no,
no problem at any site.
Thank you George.
You get out of that and I don't want to hear about him.
Few,
few weeks,
few months later,
I go to my grandma's house for having a dinner that my dad say,
you know,
come to the house a few days ago,
this guy,
I'm like,
yeah,
I met him.
He said,
yeah,
you said you met him in the street,
but now he said he came to thank you.
He came,
he wanted to talk to you,
but I said,
you don't live here and I didn't want to give you a number,
but he said,
he said,
look.
He said,
Hey George.
He talked to me and he said something,
he changed my life.
Now I have a job and I,
and I felt good.
I just wanted to say thank you to him and it feels so good now you,
Justin went and when I met him and I didn't get angry at him,
Jack,
you know,
because it's,
it was still there.
We did very bad stuff to me when I was young.
But when I see him,
it made me feel good.
Kind of a relief now.
And this guy,
when I was young,
it was beating me up in the bus all the time.
It was [inaudible] radicalize me.
I'd like,
I did that Spence,
that you can tie it like this.
It was like taking off.
And so I was that Guy Nando where in front of everybody in front of the girl,
he was beating me up all the time and it was stronger than me,
was like trees four years older than me and he was tall and strong guy.
He's a hockey player back in the day and now we,
I couldn't beat him even when Marshall,
it was always stronger than me.
He hurt me a lot,
like back in another year.
So my dad,
one time I was getting beat up in the bus.
I told him because I came back with a black eye one time in my life,
I told my dad what happened.
I never said anything by something that Dad said,
yeah,
he's a guy in a bus.
He beat me up and said,
I tell him the name of the guy.
So my dad went,
you did,
you found out where?
I'm from countryside.
So everybody knows who everybody lives.
He goes to Dallas,
you know,
I could tell it,
talk to Daddy,
say listen and stop it.
Can you tell your son to stop hitting my son in the bus because he need to be
focused on the school and the dad.
When my dad came back,
he said,
hey,
I to talk to his dad,
he's going to stop.
So he said is that it was like drinking and stuff and it was beating the shit
out of his son.
So the way
this guy learn to communicate to his dad was beating up.
He was drunk and beating him up.
That's the way he come.
He was coming in,
communicating with me.
It was beating me up because he learned that the same way from is that to
communicate.
So I was just happened to be at the right,
right,
the wrong time at the right time in his life at the perfect,
you know,
I was the guy that was getting beat.
So we say good and bad.
He wasn't not a bad person to my version of life too,
for my perspective.
It was a terrible person like them.
It was terrible.
I wanted to kill him like many May,
may I and my school time miserable man,
I was a mediated all the time.
I was getting beat up and I had,
I was very proud person.
So I used to go fight him all the time because I was proud and I want point.
I fought him so many times.
You say,
I like this guy,
he's completely,
and I stop buttering him because I was never going to giving up,
even though it was beating,
getting beat up all that time went to my own eyes.
It was a bad person,
but true.
His eyes.
It was a different star.
Ran to his father was a different story to the everybody.
It was a different story.
It just to say that when I met him that what did we talk about?
Like it feels so good just to meet him in the street and make kind of a piece
and give him money.
Like,
yeah,
you beat me up,
you didn't.
But you know why even though you did that,
I give you the money and I make me feel like I'm kind of a revenge better than
their revenge in making me feel like,
yeah man,
you see without me you wouldn't have nothing maybe to sleep or eat tonight is I
give it to you.
I still give it to you if you do that to me,
that make me feel much better than if I would like be read them up.
And don't you think that maybe that guy and him doing that to was one of the
reasons why you became a champion
because you,
you got into martial arts very heavily because of being dad because I was
beating up and the school.
Maybe it was,
but he was not the only guy that was beating me up all his friend.
But he was kind of the,
the guy that was all their girl liked and he was like the taller or stronger
guys.
So he was kind of the Alpha guy at the time.
Maybe it was an effort.
Like I said,
I don't believe only one thing influenced me.
It's many things,
many cars that make that happen,
but maybe it's one of the calls.
Yes.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
I could be wrong.
I could be right,
but that's why.
That's my philosophy in life.
That's how I think.
So everybody,
I says,
oh George,
you're a true martial artists who are a good guy as I thank you.
I don't have the time to explain to them everything I just told you.
Right,
right,
right.
But that's how I think.
And might one day and say,
you're a good guy.
I was,
I am.
Thank you.
I'm not a fucking good guy,
man.
I'm me.
I myself,
I am die.
But it made me happy.
When people say that or a good guy and you try to be a good guy.
I tried to be,
but you are who you are.
I try.
I tried to be good model.
A good role model I think is important for me to my value that had been raised,
you know,
but doesn't mean like I don't like other guys.
I like the guys that I liked the most to,
to,
to watch their fight.
They're another good guy.
My favorite fighters to watch are not the good guys.
You Sauna and I like to watch him.
Nick Z eyes.
I like to watch Nick Diaz.
I like Conor McGregor when he fights.
I like him.
Yeah,
they're good.
Guys are boring man.
They boring guys.
You're making me fall asleep.
I like the drummer.
I like even though I don't act like it.
I like it.
We won't be.
I know it's completely contradictory.
I like,
I love the Tito Ortiz.
Back in the day was my favorite man.
Story.
T's man.
He was amazing.
Came with his flag like bad,
bad guy and I loved it.
Man.
Star Wars.
I love their sin,
Lord much.
They're much more charismatic than the jet.
I are you shitting me,
Jed?
I [inaudible] the new,
the new karate kid.
I watched the first episode of moping Daniel's son get beat up all the time.
You know,
Johnny Lorenz,
I hope he smashes his head that you didn't do it.
So,
you know what I mean?
That make me a bad person.
No,
it's just,
I like,
you know,
it's different the way that's how you see things,
you know?
Right.
When you see a lion chasing the gazelle,
do you root for the gazelle?
I hope the light catches it gives.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Is that good or bad?
Like if people and only eat meat,
there's nothing natural.
Right?
It's like what is natural?
What isn't that natural man?
It's an interesting conversation when you talk about this.
If people think God,
your savior is just so you just get hit and they had to do too many times,
but it's just,
it's just not now.
My,
my English is good.
I can communicate it.
True truth with you like,
yeah.
Like it's easier,
I feel more call affordable.
Yeah.
And,
and it,
it is what it is.
But I I,
that's why I like it because you're a person too.
I'm kind of a big fan of youtube and I know you,
I didn't know that in the beginning when I first to know you,
but I now I know that,
that you get interested in the same thing that I am interested and what I like
about usual is you don't give a damn.
You do whatever.
You have no bus,
you do whatever you want whenever you want.
We who you won't.
And me,
I'd respect that.
It's kind of a code.
You have your own code that you do and I respect that.
I like human being like this.
I like to,
to be
with human being like this guys,
I have no code and we're like this.
Me and my circle of friend is shortening and I have a few guy,
I like him.
I said,
I keep the,
the,
I'm diplomatic with a lot of people,
but I'm not friends with a lot of people and some blue Maddie because have to be
for the,
for my work,
for my business,
for the person I am,
and I don't like golf rotations.
I'm diplomatic,
but there's a mean.
I like everybody,
you know.
Well,
I think your relationships that you have with people,
the exchanges you have with people,
it's very important to keep only positive,
influential,
strong people around you because you learn and you grow from those people and
they give you fuel when you're around people who are inspirational or doing
interesting things,
who live their life by a code,
who are ambitious,
who succeeded,
who try hard,
difficult things,
those are the people that had spire and give you energy.
And I feel better around them.
I feel like I get energy from them versus people that are always making excuses
and people that are always falling short.
People that fail all the time and people that complain all the time,
those people are the opposite.
And those people,
they take away from you and you're around them.
You just like,
oh,
I just got to get away from this guy.
I however,
it doesn't mean that the good people that you have in your life will always be
the good people for different situation.
Example,
before I fight my families,
I stayed the hell away from them and I explain it to wire cause my family,
they care about me.
I remember before fights,
before I used to go eat at my and my parent with my parent,
my family,
it used to be like the last dinner.
They,
they,
there are soup.
They look at me,
are you okay?
You feel good,
you're not sick ag.
And um,
and I,
before I fight,
I need to feel like I'm going to war with my soldier Allie to fill that what I'm
doing,
it's normal events though,
is not,
so when I hang out with,
with my family,
they have a normal life.
So what I do,
they see me like an outcast.
I collect man.
He's the guy he's is,
he's completely insane.
He's about to go fight.
And the gauge,
you can die.
Oh my God.
And I feel that because I love me.
So my family before the fight,
stay away from them.
I stay away from a lot of the people that I love that are in my circle of
friends or,
or real people.
I love it like family.
And I bring back closer to people like,
like Feras Joan,
and they had a fighter's guys,
even guys that are maybe not as much as my friend a day.
Like she don't understand the mentality.
Yes.
So it make me feel normally make me feel strong because we're going to war.
When you're going to war,
you don't bring in.
Yeah.
Why?
If you're a kid,
your family,
uh,
you bring the people that you go into war with.
You know what I mean?
It's very important for me.
So it's,
it's depending what's going on.
I believe it's good and bad people,
you know,
it's not always good.
Not always bad,
depending on the context,
you know?
Yeah,
no,
that makes a lot of sense.
That makes a lot of sense.
Especially them being nervous about your fight.
Like big nerve that that energy is contagious pro.
I'm already nervous like,
like it is.
I don't want to be more nervous and I hate,
I hate like I hate to fighting people's,
I know you had Donald is,
I really do and I know you're maybe a lot of people don't,
don't believe me,
but I'm going to try to explain the best I can
in every,
in every jobs there is no perfect job.
Do we agree that there is,
there's no job that you like everything about it.
It's impossible.
My job as a professional athlete and mixed martial art untree Android's 65 days.
I F I fight when I was very excited.
I used to fight twice a year approximately that much more than that.
I never wanted it to more than that'd be good.
I want it to stretch suspicion,
winery sh you want to stretch when you're a champion because it's better for for
advertising.
The,
the also for longevity and everything.
So we more time,
more money,
more business wise on everything and longevity.
So about twice a year in trudge at 65 days.
There's two days that I hate the most is that day that I'm fighting.
It's freaking unbearable.
The feeling event certainty that if you don't know,
if you're going to be humiliated,
you're going to be the victor.
We are going to be the loser.
It's,
I care so much about it that he is freaking I'm bare boat.
As much as I tried to dismiss it,
it's unbearable.
However,
I liked the fact that I'm a free man.
I'm my own bus.
I do whatever it ever read over Av,
AV access to certain things like VIP stuff that most people don't.
And my quality of life,
uh,
the money,
I didn't have it before.
Now I do.
I love my job,
am very happy about my job,
but there is thing about my job that I hate.
Demos is fighting.
I freaking hate.
I love the study of fighting.
I love the science of it.
How,
um,
the tactical,
the physical.
I love to train.
I love to walk in a room for the strong.
I know if something happened,
I'm the demand.
Even though it's an illusion because it with a bullet and nobody's faster than
this,
but I liked that lifestyle.
I do it for the lifestyle,
for what it is.
I don't do it for the fight.
I freaking hate to fight.
I had this talk with Robert McDonald wound boy,
and I was like,
hey,
why are you like fighting?
Oh,
I guess I like to fight.
He said,
you'd like to fight.
Is that you?
Fuck now I know,
and I,
and everybody in that room turn around.
They look at me like I'm crazy.
I'm like,
you guys are all crazy.
They got active fight the nic cage and 1 million of people maybe getting
mediated,
knocked out or die.
Are you crazy?
I don't like to fight.
I,
you're nuts.
I like to win.
When you win,
you're,
it's,
the feeling is unbelievable.
It's so good that it's worth this,
but I hate it,
man.
Do you hate the day of the fight up until the fight,
but once the fight starts,
how do you feel once it starts then and then,
no,
and when it started,
it's gone.
I'll listen to all the anticipation.
I hate the day the buildup that they,
and the closer we get to the day I start,
I love it,
but I start to hate it more.
It's like a build ahead that build up like a bubble of hate.
And by that time that it's time to freak and walk out there like the
many second.
That is time to walk out.
And I burnt.
Watson used to be the guy used to kick out the door.
Sorry.
Yeah,
you ready?
Now he's not there anymore,
unfortunately
Colin Bro.
So I used,
it's like a bubble that build up in my stomach that hate,
hate,
hate.
Then I freaking hate that I'm even in the locker room before the fight and I
fucking hated my last fight.
I,
it's crazy.
I saw my friend,
Amen.
Gag knocked out and I'm glad the dinner,
everybody's like dead people like this and,
and has,
she wears something as long as they were just wrong.
And he's like,
they told themselves before I get into the room,
we don't tell them that,
that amen last.
Don't tell him he's just going to affect him.
So I get into their room and my friend Eddie,
who was in there one day,
when they tell each other,
first thing he says to me is,
I get numbers I amen.
Loss.
Oh,
he's okay physically is that?
Yeah,
is okay.
And everybody's like,
Whoa,
what are you shit.
So Emma last,
I remember Joe de Filez,
Micky gall loss.
So I go in my room in my locker room,
I see one guy with the ice bag,
the other guy is all fucked up like this and I'm like,
man,
all my locker room lose man.
Oh Holy Shit.
I freaking hate this job,
man.
Then I'm thinking is like everybody tried to make me take like,
oh,
he's going to be good is one of my agents like tone where everybody is going to
be fine as I as I,
it's okay man.
Don't talk to me like this.
I choose be here,
I'm,
I'm a warrior and a,
it's a goal.
Go sit now.
It's going to be fine.
Like I want it to be a warrior.
I don't want to be that high.
It's going to be fine.
Don't worry.
You know,
they go negative.
Yeah.
He was that first time they go like this guy,
they grabbed me like dory,
dory,
it's gotta be fine and it'll keep charter.
Is Heidi by a news Islam?
Everybody on the,
on his head all these years.
Um,
I'm feeling like I'm going to,
uh,
I guess are like a cemetery.
Like someone just died.
So I'm in the locker room.
Everybody,
if we can lose,
I'm like,
Damn.
Then I'm like,
yeah,
you shake it up.
I go in the bathroom by myself.
I go,
I go look myself in the mirror and that's why I do.
Before the fight I used James Lounge theory.
James.
Now James is a,
they say that the spirit can dictate your mind is a you,
you're thirsty,
you're mind tells I'm thirsty.
You grabbed the water and your spirit can dictate your mind,
but your mind can dictate your spirit.
So I go in the bathroom,
close the door.
People would think I go to bedroom to piss or whatever,
but I don't,
it goes to the door and I say,
I say,
now I see a lot of negative shit.
I go,
I go in front of the mirror and say,
I say to my son,
I say,
I tried to convince myself like a kid.
You know,
like I'm the greatest.
I'm the stronger as I know.
And I think,
I think I would look at me and I'm this,
I'm beautiful,
I'm stone and this,
I know I'm faster,
I'm stronger.
I'm getting a win as like these young guy they lose.
But I'm going to show them what the w the way to do it,
you know?
And maybe they fell,
but I won't.
I'm going to show everybody always should be done,
man.
So I come back in the gym,
go with the,
with the glory to show them that I achieve it and that's how it should be done
if they're going to follow me.
So I try boobs,
my eyes then open that are go,
go back.
I still hate my job,
but I am a different person than when I got in the door.
So I play with mind games like this with myself all the time.
It's stuff that I had tried to change your attitude and it's very important for
our fighter because the confidence is a key for a fighter.
Some guy,
they do stuff very basic and a I,
but they do it.
When they do it.
They do it so good.
Then they believe in it.
They're not hesitate and you have no room for visitation and a fight.
You go 100% and when you go 100% with confidence,
that's when the magic can happen.
You know what I mean?
If you have there the tat,
the skills,
but you don't have the confidence is in is John says that that you have the
skills and they have no confidence.
It's like having money when you don't spend it.
That's what John and Eric on me.
But if you have the confidence without the skills,
it's not good to,
it's like a dream that cannot be achieved.
You don't have the any way together,
but you have boat.
That's when the magic can happen.
I remember when John,
John,
he says that to me all the time,
so you have the skill and you have the confidence and confidence is not a choice
is that is it a confidence isn't that is not a state of mind is a choice and
then you can build it in your head when something bad happened,
you build it and work,
tried to work on your person to build it.
This is something you can work on yourself,
you know,
and that's why I've been doing,
yeah,
it's like all these other things you're saying it's,
there's no,
there's no one answer to how all of this is done.
All of those pieces have to come together.
All those pieces have to be together in order for you to be able to just go out
there and do it.
But I love the fact that you say that you don't like it.
I freaking hate it.
I hate it.
Probably even in their locker room when I got there,
what I've got there that night and like every other night that I'm finding as by
my agent ask to ask.
Even for Assa.
I always tell them,
I look at him as like,
so what the hell I'm doing here or whatnot.
I got so stupid as you're like,
oh my God,
and they always laugh at it because now it becomes at that point that I know,
I know it.
People say with experience or you do become more courageous,
do you become,
how do you say,
do you lose the fair?
You don't lose every,
never lose a fair.
You will learn how to deal with it.
You accept it.
Before I didn't,
I didn't get accepted in my earlier fight like Matthew was.
My first time I found my [inaudible] man,
I was fighting this monument.
They say,
oh my God.
I was like,
I didn't city for the week,
man.
I came like Africans Zombie.
I was like,
oh my God,
I can't even in this third down,
I couldn't even look at him.
I look up like this.
It's like I couldn't imagine myself as I knew I was going to lose the
confidence,
wasn't it?
There have the skip was another confidence,
so it's is very important.
The confidence know is for a fighter.
Confidence is very important.
That's why you have guys in the gym that are very good in the gym.
They get into a fight,
they shitty fighter.
They came in the gym,
they go into a fight,
all of that stuff.
Garage,
you have guys,
they're normal in the gym.
I've seen guys in UFC day fight the UFC.
Dave frigging bad.
I can't say for their respect,
but I spar with them and they suck.
When they fight,
they do stuff that it's amazing.
I'm like,
I didn't even know it.
That wasn't his repertoire of techniques.
They just did it.
I'm like,
man,
it's amazing.
I didn't even know he knew that because of confidence,
man.
And when you have bowed this,
get into confidence and I you see like John Jones,
man,
his magic man,
you go with there and pop,
pop,
pop as spinning,
frigging elbows and supply.
You don't hesitate.
He goes,
man,
you're Rodriguez.
He's amazing.
Ban and stuff like that.
It's just beautiful to watch.
You know,
and I really liked that.
The new generation man is carriers.
Oh my God,
what?
X,
which fight excites you more,
Connor?
Or it could be,
but those are the two fights.
If I was going to make a fight for your right,
right,
right now,
right now it's like the big five.
The thing is with Kbb,
calling me out physically now is not good time for me and he and neat the way a
little bit.
However I feel that one 55 division now is scanner is the champion is forgive
somebody.
I think Ferguson is out and,
and there's other guys too,
but there's the two guy,
Carter and cabby
cabby now I think he's that trap you in,
but the need to fight maybe the corner or are are to be like a champion.
He's the real chart.
I don't like to say they really not champion and my opinion on the belt is
really different than most people think.
I don't think even think you should be at belt.
You know?
I think it should be fight,
you know by then,
but it is what it is and make fun.
Fight.
There's no belt is you cannot be the strongest men in the world is I need
illusion.
The belt it claim it elevates on one like you think he's a god.
He's a strongest today and men and in that now he's not.
What's a good marketing tool that that rank guide that can beat you,
but maybe you cannot be the seven other in front of you or they say,
you know what I mean?
There's six either,
so I don't know how he could be done.
I know it's bad to criticize a system if you don't suggest any alternative.
I know it's better with I do,
but it's,
well,
the problem is in flux anyway,
right?
Because Tony was the interim champion and he didn't do anything to lose it.
All we do is fall down while doing press obligations is terrorists,
Nia part.
Then you have Connor who just didn't defend it and then they stripped him and so
you're going to give it to Khabib,
but he's fighting our Quinta who ordinarily wouldn't be fighting for the title.
So why is,
why is he have the potential to fight for the title?
It doesn't make any sense.
They just had to do it for this event because they had this big event in
Brooklyn and they had to have a champion,
so they decided to sell.
They're going to do it.
But you gotta be careful when you make decisions like that.
Yeah.
Because you in many people's eyes and the eyes of the purists,
you de legitimize.
It loses value.
Yes,
I agree 100% it loses value to it.
Especially like,
like what I did make lose value to fight and drinks left the fight.
Bisping left.
They fricken hate my guts.
So that's why I don't think so though,
because I think it's not good for the brand is not good and I know it's not
good.
I'm,
I'm not stupid.
I realize it,
but I had no choice man.
I go back there,
I had in condition,
you know what I mean?
But I think it was not my aim.
Robbie Lawler won the title and then Robbie Lawler lost the title,
the Tyrone Woodley.
Nobody doesn't think Tyron Woodley is the legitimate champion because you
retired.
No,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a clear path.
It makes sense.
Then on that is the same thing.
Like I said,
it's not WWE man.
I have to do what is the best for me and then,
and I don't regret my decision.
I regret that I stayed too long.
I should have retire.
Maybe take my first stop after the as cause Diaz was the fight,
the big fight and what,
you know what I mean?
It was the main guy you know,
to fight then after Russia,
but there's always that guy Joe,
that's that thing.
There's always another,
if we can guide as a way this sport,
you know we always believe that after that wall it will be no wall,
but now man is always another,
another,
another.
And then I realized that it's an,
every fight are more expected than other and now are bigger than the other and
it is what it is,
man.
This is what it is.
It's a hard,
very hard life mentally like depending on your wire.
Psychologically for me it was a lot to take.
Well I think it's not a lot to say for me.
I have a theory about that.
One of the reasons why it's a lot to takes cause you're smart.
I think smart people,
they,
they entertain all the possibilities.
They think about all the possibilities.
They're aware of all the variables.
I,
I'm,
I'm a thinker.
I think I lost.
Yeah.
And allies I take a lot.
I mean it's good because it's prepared you very well and it's made you this
incredible martial artists.
But it's also,
it creates a lot of anxiety because you're aware of all the possibilities.
Whereas a person who doesn't think that much,
it's just,
I'm just going to go in there and fuck people up.
Like that person might have an easier path to fight,
but they might also have a shorter limited potential.
Absolutely.
Cause they're not aware of all the possibilities and they're not aware of all
their flaws and all not aware of other strengths and weaknesses.
They just know what they've done that's worked and they just keep doing that.
And instead of developing this incredibly well rounded game,
they have a very,
very,
uh,
limited game.
But that limited game works on some people.
I agree.
It's,
it's,
it's this sport,
the sport in general.
It's Kinda,
it's Kinda not fair when you look at it.
Like,
look at Demetrius Johnson.
Spraberry right now.
The best ever.
Yeah,
I agree.
Like man,
when I talk about confidence and skills,
man weathers the better guide in this.
What better guide and this Dominik Cruz freaking amazing.
Uh,
man,
Tj Dillashaw that's one fight.
Look,
I don't watch every fight.
I came,
I don't watch every fight because I'm not a fan of every fighter,
but if there's a fight that I will pay my home to get to sit in front and fly
myself.
Is Dominick,
uh,
Demetrius Johnson against Tj Dillashaw?
Absolutely.
I eman they asked to be done.
This is what has to be done.
Crazy.
I agree.
I don't,
there was always things and in fact,
or that we don't know why it doesn't happen.
Maybe we don't know where everything unfortunately.
And um,
yeah,
like,
like back in the Damien Anderson Silva is a lot of the didn't happen.
And is there stuff that people don't know that led that back in the day I taught
and then I wanted to take care of it didn't happen,
but they,
there's this fight man.
It's just crazy man.
Sometime he sat in this sport like,
like you have a fight like Mayweather,
Mayweather Pacquiao and it did not happen.
It sucked.
But it is what it is,
you know?
Well,
I think that Demetrius wants Tj Dillashaw to fight once at 125 pounds.
Show that he can make the weight,
especially when he's dealing with this incredibly long wind streak.
He's defended his title more than any other champion ever.
So he doesn't want someone to come along and break his wind street.
It doesn't even make it the way they,
this as a,
I have thought about this because I've been in this similar situation.
This is a way to take care of this with the lawyers you write in the contract
that if don't make weight is no fight and the purse,
you make the guy paying you what purse,
not the UFC dealer show would take the papers,
give the purse.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
No I do,
but I think it'd be game enough to do it.
It's a freaking risk.
Yeah.
But I think Demetrius is worried that the UFC would pressure him into fighting
Tj,
even if Tj doesn't make the weight.
So we have Tj Maxx for sure.
For sure.
You make it will make him look bad in terms of with the fan base and his Bram
Agri.
However we can make it through the lawyer to the,
if it's that much weight difference,
there was no fight.
Right.
You know,
there's always fights.
Men,
Joe,
there's something I haven't learned.
Fight can be negotiated the way you want.
I can negotiate a fight like depending the the laws.
Okay.
I want you to wear pink a speedos when I,
if I do,
it's under contract.
You have to wear a spring speedo.
I want you to wear this or,
or any fifth round or if it's everything could be done.
If it's written and,
and,
and by the law.
Uh,
agreed.
Yeah.
It could be worked out.
I don't think Demetrius do.
Whether it be worked out this guys,
let's do it,
man.
Let's go.
Well,
I think right now the rematch has set for Cody Garbrandt versus Tj Dillashaw and
mighty mouse just went through shoulder surgery.
He's rehabilitating your shoulder.
That's going to take quite a while and there there's Dominik Dominik Cruz to win
that mixed match.
He's amazing.
I like to watch him a lot.
Yeah,
there's a lot of talent.
There's a lot of talent in the UFC right now that that smaller guy are so much
better than the bigger guy.
I am betting you that true.
Like,
like if I would have that same size as these guy,
man,
I don't want to fight these guy,
man.
I wish they would beat the shit out of me.
Like no man,
they don't have gravity fucking with them aggregate.
They know that that gravity,
they're not have that size.
But there are so good man.
It's so good to watch them.
I'm learning.
I'm learning a lot.
I watch a lot more of these guide and then in terms of for learning men,
I'll beautiful.
Was that on Bard at Demetrius Johnson?
Did I shit Medis slam slam to the arm bar in the air and he,
no,
I practice it.
Been trading learned.
I learned from these guy,
man.
I learned from a lot of these guys.
Yeah.
Tj Dillashaw he switch men every time he's changing.
Beautiful.
Dominick Cruz man,
his footwork and said same trained with Duane Ludwig a longtime ago.
Yes.
I have a spar w we train a,
when I was in Denver helping Nathan Marquardt for a fight.
I spar.
Uh,
Manny was crazy.
Spar with Dwayne,
Nate,
Shane cat when through all my was Shane car.
That was that smart.
But I did.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
Yeah,
that wasn't that smart.
I was back in the day.
Maybe I should have been smarter.
Man is as big as your head.
Thanks God.
I didn't get heard but oh my God.
It was,
yeah.
I won't point remember anything in a training.
[inaudible]
it wasn't grounded.
Pounded with another guy that is like a light everywhere.
He knock him out.
Yeah.
He's uh,
he's that big monster.
But that was stupid on my part.
When you're young,
you do stupid shit.
I should not have done it.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
Huh?
Where did he weigh back then?
You ways,
either me or him.
I just say,
man,
hey car Whitney's,
it might be like,
yeah,
he's a big guy.
Fucking huge.
And I know it.
That was stupid,
but I did it and then I,
you know,
you move man.
You gotta fucking move.
Yeah man.
He hit,
I hit and run.
Man Doesn't run.
Don't try to stand in their pocket with this guy.
And if you go for a take down,
you go in and out and then quick man,
Holy Shit.
Your timing has to be perfect.
Fuck that.
The only one round one round.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
All right.
As far as we went with everybody,
you know,
and there's this thing like I,
I,
when we train with the other guys,
especially guys I train with David,
everybody I traveled with Jon Jones,
I tried to,
it was part with everybody,
which it's,
it's,
it's good experience there,
you know?
And there's guys that,
that spar like it's our life depends on it.
Like it's a real fight.
There's other guys of course,
depending if you get ready for a fight or not and if it,
depending on the situation,
but there is when it's just a spring for spring that you're not in training camp
or whatever,
you spar.
But there are still guys that I see younger guy day they,
they load,
they lose a lot of their,
their years of fighting in the gym because they fight in the gym and he snuck
good for your brain man.
Holy Shit.
I never be a big,
been a big fan of this.
I feel like even now in my last spring guys a Camarda,
I mean,
but I have to go hard because otherwise they're going to hurt me.
But that's not because of meat as because my freaking trainer is telling them,
you got to put him away.
We're going to praise it or know what I mean.
So why does for us do that?
He's completely,
completely crazy for her ass man.
He's insane.
I love him to death.
But man,
he's completely insane.
He's,
my son sees my A's Pie.
He May,
I called him,
pay me John.
I do.
You know what,
John,
I call him the emperor.
The Emperor John Ice though or that you would,
they all have nicknames.
That's hilarious man.
Man.
They,
they,
they tough guy.
John is another one.
Like when I'm in training camp and he put me with Gordon Ryan,
the Gabby throw it in one after Jake Shit,
I gotta go,
go,
go a damn man.
I get smashed.
I get out like a pretzel.
Like
sometime it's not good for my coffin and sometime it is.
Sometime I'm like,
shit man.
I just,
it's hard to tell.
I have a hard life is a darkness inside John's brain.
Yeah,
man.
And it's hard.
It's hard,
man.
I made it,
I made a lot of good change for preparation.
Like,
you know,
I used to train like in on the ground,
I find the wing fight around a five minute.
You'd have,
we're going to spend five minutes on the ground when you train for an MMA fight.
So I did treatment around when one minute break in make you and starting form
scrambling position like Nepal had had an arm control then go right or mount
position Gopal we didn't start like shaken and then because you lose time while
you making,
so we start from position control at end goal.
So he make you more active in when you fight,
make you more reports on this stick.
That's how I,
and now I teach at Tristar 12 for rest.
Like I do it because I love it at 12 Ferris and that's why I teach the people
no,
no more five minute round when you drain for and it made me a fight two minute
round,
three minute round and a stone and you will never spend the entire five minute
round there.
The minute that you get to spend on the ground that you have to be very economic
and very important is when you see something,
boom.
That's how I got into a fight with Bisping.
I see the neck boom,
I let him stand up,
do the,
the the leg,
drag it up right away.
I probably would not have reacted the same way a few years ago,
which would be more taking a position and safe kind of mentality.
You know what I mean?
That we need to learn it too.
Yeah,
it was this way,
but I practice it a lot because I learned the pattern of Bisping that when you
do this,
he liked to do with this.
So I predict we've,
we've,
we've worked on it,
you know,
like when I mean like it's stuff that we worry wasn't in my,
like I said,
like my,
uh,
my autopilot already in my hard disk.
So it's just reaction.
You don't know what to have time to think,
which before,
when you don't train like this,
you're trained in five minute,
it's slower pace or you're thinking more Shih Tzu is,
is more,
uh,
um,
it's not much of a dynamic.
It's more easy metric.
Sport.
Sometime you did make that is more,
is symmetric and position.
So you don't want to be like this for him and you want to be like bang,
Bang,
Bang fast.
And you know what I mean?
Make your,
make you more,
you know what I mean?
More efficient.
What kind of training you're doing now?
I mean you,
you're going to train with Freddie Roach now.
See how much time are you spending training?
I try.
I try normally twice a day.
Everyday still.
Yeah.
I don't train hard every day.
Twice a day.
Some days I do once a day.
I tried to train at least four days a week that are twice a day and maybe two
days that are a once a day at depending what I do.
Uh,
for example,
I wanted to get on a train one.
So day to day is with Freddy tomorrow have a,
I do it,
this new thing now it's,
that really changed my life to it.
I trained in a pool and all lift weight you don't live with now man.
I don't,
I don't really,
I still don't believe in conditioning.
You say conditioning.
I don't believe,
I believe it's an illusion.
Everybody has a,
it's efficiency.
So I want to get tired more than the others because more efficient cause
everybody had their stores on level is in shape.
You know what I mean?
But,
but I trained in the pool.
I do,
uh,
for example,
I have resistance stuff,
equipment and I trained in the post.
So it's like my weight training aid,
we in a pool,
like it's what you do,
flies we have.
Uh,
but that guidance is not that good.
And this is my soul that works all the time.
And it's like doing flies,
but instead of that yet,
but agonists and antagonists,
you do,
I fly and,
and,
and the,
and the pool in the same time,
Bush Paul,
and you're doing it with rubber bands resistance.
No resistance equipment is like,
uh,
Shit.
I wish I would know where your table,
no,
Eh,
it's not a capital a resistant,
it's like a handle and send,
you would think they're Russian developed this like in days long time ago where
we just start to learn now about it.
And the Russian were way more advanced than us in the,
in the,
it's ea Gavin Mcmullin that made me discover this form of training when I at
Rehab,
my ACO.
So he,
um,
he hates to weight training.
He said Ha,
weight training.
They load up your joint damage,
your joints,
you know it depending on what you do it,
but when you go evi damaged your joining.
It is true.
That's why I stay.
I look young and I feel better at 37 now.
If it wouldn't be for this,
my,
my old sir,
I feel better now at 37 that I felt like 25 mark.
My word is true.
The only differences let's I go out with like my birthday was may 19 last
Saturday I got completely wasted drunk.
It takes me more days to recuperate because I'm 37 and when I was 25 but
strength wise like I feel just more powerful.
Better.
Hmm.
Yeah man.
We,
there is hope for the older men there.
There is hope that we can lasts better.
We can have a better living.
It's kind of crazy that you don't believe it's strength and condition.
I don't think that is the thing that everybody does today.
Now I know that he's involved with strength and conditioning because sometime
they mixed up their performance and strength conditioning because of the
steroid.
I believe.
I love people.
They say,
oh,
my new nutrition is because of this,
this,
or my new training,
make me be stronger.
Look,
I'm a better fighter and man,
maybe it's because you taking something,
you know what I mean?
I believe and UFC like let's say I spar with some pro box.
Okay.
Uh,
for example like yes you right here.
Yeah.
This one an example.
So you've got low ankle weights on.
So what it is,
oh,
but they create that resistance on the way up.
You see?
So it's so,
so he doesn't load up my joint and you just explode.
Again.
This is like pistol squat,
but I,
there's like a hundreds,
like a exercise like this,
like I sounded with maybe not a hundred,
but they,
there's so many.
Yeah man.
There's that you can do with your,
every part of your buddy,
you can do an exercise and the Russians got it too.
Yes.
And,
and also the NFL football player payroll a lot train with that because it
increase your power in works.
So that thing that you don't have is the stability.
But if you want to increase your power,
it helped for increasing the power of four muscle,
the fiber of the muscle.
You know what I mean?
It won't make you a better fighter but it will longevity wise keep your,
your car,
your,
your vehicle,
your vehicle.
Ltr.
That's why I do strength conditioning.
I don't do for making me a better fighter.
I do it because I want to look good.
I want to be muscular,
I want to,
I want to be a balance.
I want to be at a longer longevity.
It's not going to make me hit harder or stronger.
Cal Know Freddie Roach might help me hit stronger for example.
You know what I mean?
John,
that hour would make me be more creative.
I have better on bars and the fair Ras would make me,
you know what I mean?
Like better fighter and in terms of giving me knowledge and different things
that that's what I believe could be wrong or like,
like I know we think different ways in that regard.
We argued before I bought this,
but that's why I've been eating open minded and when a lot of times when I'm
arguing,
I'm just playing the devil's advocate.
I don't think there's any one way to do these things.
Like example,
I spar for example,
or you're a Jujitsu guy,
make it an experimentation.
Go wrestle or with a real wrestler,
like a high level wrestler,
pure wrestler,
right?
Wrestle with him.
You're going to get much.
If you're going to get tired much quicker than him for sure it's not because
he's got a better car do within you,
you know?
Or maybe he is it like I did depending,
but then after that go on the ground,
sit down and shake his hand and start rolling on the ground.
I guarantee he's going to get more tired than you because if you never,
then Jujitsu is going to spend a lot more energy is again,
you're going to be much more efficient than him even though maybe as a better
car in and then you,
if you take a vo two Max test,
maybe he's going to score better.
However you're more efficient.
It's all about efficiency.
Yeah.
They tried to sell you the product,
they tried to sell you the program.
They tell it's all freaking out for Thai advertising or life is made of
advertising.
That's why I was angry.
And I like,
we talk about intermittent fast thing,
like there's no pills for it is there is nobody that makes money.
That's why nobody talks about it.
But it's efficient.
The oldest remedy in the world,
you know what I mean?
In three days you can rebuild your,
your immune system and your gut.
All,
all of it in three days are fascinating.
You do it.
Take an Mli assault with di water.
You go train is perfect.
You go in autophagy phases their best,
you know I am,
but nobody talks about the same thing in,
in cards,
zoo and all that.
They have to commercialize eyes.
Their money is it,
it's all about selling you the thing or life.
It's all about branding.
Everywhere we'll go with freaking commercial.
We were surround by commercial if you want it.
And it's something that we don't even realize it because it's so present in our
life.
So it's,
it's,
uh,
it's not gonna make me a better fighter.
I do it because I fell good,
developed my muscle.
It is good for me to be,
you know,
to have a muscle for,
for my brand,
for,
for me,
for advertising,
for even for myself,
felt good.
You know what I mean?
Joey fell silent,
you know,
and I get it.
Yeah,
that's a real true it.
It's not going to make me hit you think this is gonna make me have a better
hook.
No,
man,
it's,
it doesn't transcend like that,
right.
Timing.
Precision a forms,
you know,
everything.
You,
it's not the,
if Georgia has had the smallest arm I think is one of the smallest army hit like
crazy.
Hey Daddy,
when you look at his build,
he wasn't like a Mike Tyson or a Lennox Lewis.
My friend had done is Stevenson like,
I mean he's,
Bill is on the hill,
he's an athlete.
But man,
I spar with him many times.
He hit like fucking track is probably the heaviest hitter ever seen in my life
and what I mean,
and he's not like,
he's strong,
he's athletic.
But there is guide more.
More should look,
look stronger to him or bodybuilder.
Yeah,
because that's because of his form.
The weight transfer,
his weight is,
is vector of force.
Everything.
His technique,
his timing's precision.
Everything is boom,
don't you?
They're a fakey bone structure to a little bit too,
right?
You actually power your freaking bad kick man.
Like this is something,
isn't it?
Because you were there and I said
the human being that have hit,
that had produced the highest amount of force that I have ever witnessed in my
life is human,
which are free.
And I'm not gonna say it like this.
This is their truth.
I never seen a human being physically capable of hitting something with that
much force than you is that perfect example of what the,
of what we argue.
It's not because you're stronger.
Yeah.
You strong guy,
you're a good athletic guy,
but you know,
like you're,
you're older,
you're older than me,
you know,
and I like,
you know what I mean?
Like why?
Because this is your form to technique.
The vector of forced your technique.
Everything is all freaking perfect timing.
That's why when you turn in,
you make that spill out.
I don't care who you are.
If you find this,
and again,
do you hit that shit on their face,
you going to be dead.
You know,
and I'm not there,
but you're going to be knocked out,
man.
This is crazy.
You know what I mean?
When you did that,
there wasn't a completely insane,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's the one.
I'm still working on it,
but a way,
but I,
I can't do like you do with my knee coming out.
I feel like when I do inspiring the guys,
they see it and they,
so I have to keep my knee tuck.
I think you're just thinking that maybe it's because of karate.
I learned in a different way,
so my,
my brain is wired so much in a certain way.
The problem with karate is that lower knee than need down by the,
the other knee versus up by the hip.
When you bring it up by the hip,
there's,
there's much more leverage.
There's tremendous amount of force and the alignment of your lower leg,
the supporting leg and the kicking leg is better to generate force,
whereas the kicking leg is almost independent of the lower leg if you're going
up because they're not moving in the same direction.
One leg is going up,
the other ladies going forward,
so it's like,
Eh,
it's all goofy when the hip is up,
when you turn,
the hip is up.
This is pushing and this is going forward.
It's just so boom,
I wherever.
It's where the power comes from.
However,
do you you,
you come from taekwondo.
Is all the Olympic athlete like champion?
They don't do it like that.
No.
They don't know exactly that you do with the different ways.
Right.
I never seen anybody hit as hard like I don't care if it's a punch,
like I never see a strike,
a strike.
I blow from a human being that hard,
man.
I remember that.
That bag when you were working in it was I fricking whole lot of us in the bag.
It was like a curves and the bag,
like with your,
your footprint in it.
It's sculpted.
Insane man.
It's a lot of power.
I was with Bravo way that I remember we were freaking out then you want to going
back and forward and I like,
you know we worked together because of Donna her.
Yeah,
cause John came up to me and just asking me because I was a commentator,
he said I need someone to help George with the fundamentals of is spinning back
kick.
He needs like a,
like a technique refresher.
Do you know anybody?
And I said,
this is gonna sound crazy.
I could just gotta to listen to me but I have a really good spinning back kick.
So that's how,
that's how you put it out.
Just smart.
I said he put,
he put it to me just asking.
No,
no,
he would taekwondo.
He knew.
He said no,
he knew that.
He told me he's going to ask you is going to ask if you could work with me.
That's funny because he said it to me.
No,
no,
no.
Now,
but you want to put it this way.
It's John,
John Johnny's smart guy.
John,
he's very smart guy at at at w you would have,
if we'd had have said he would have kind of right because he,
I remember he said that to me and I say,
because he's like my son,
so he's in my,
in my,
in my size,
I,
Yay.
Right?
I'm like,
Nah.
I was rolling my eyes like,
what the fuck is Joe Rogan?
I didn't know what your background,
you know like I knew,
I know you did some marsh.
I thought he was going to think no,
but he knew that because our word get around.
That word gets around that you have a very strong spinning back,
kick it somewhere.
Somehow told him or he's seen it or B because he told me,
I remember he told me.
Then I was like,
Yay,
I'll do it when I go and train with Freddie Roach and I then I,
then I couldn't believe it.
I called him the same night.
I said,
what the fuck was that?
It was like,
this should be an elite.
If he ever have fights,
mount is there should be a Lego.
You can kill someone with this van is insane,
man.
What's fucked up is it almost feels like a lie because it was so long ago.
It was a different life.
Like I stopped fighting.
I'm 50 years old.
I stopped fighting when I was 21 so I haven't fought in forever.
So it's just I've,
I keep doing it and training,
but I haven't done it so long.
So when I tell someone that I can do it,
am I dizzy?
Assess,
is that true?
I'd be like saying,
is it true?
How many people did you,
did you ever lie it up?
Someone with that video of me when I was 19 from a taekwondo tournament.
Megan,
a guy fly through the air.
Yeah,
I you serious tube?
Yeah.
Jamie.
Oh my God.
Is He okay now?
Is He alive or no?
Here it is right here.
Okay.
Are you kidding me man?
Yeah.
That's how fucking scratchy VHS video from 1986 you realize you didn't even cut
him.
Like,
you know,
we talk about precision,
like there was like w your technique is freaking price.
So powerful.
Like you got him where on the shoulder on the,
no,
I caught him on the body.
It wasn't in the shoulder.
You can see it again,
but yeah,
it's okay.
It's just his arm is underneath his arm.
But I,
and put on that guy always because it's very encouraged.
The incredibly powerful I guy would do the same thing it him and the same spot.
It would probably be not get put away like that.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
See a z,
see the impact.
It goes right into his body.
And then I extend and then when I extended he was,
I was Kinda like,
yeah,
hi.
Yeah.
You see no,
no.
And that was,
that was perfect.
And he just sailed through the air.
It's just,
it's a crazy,
it's,
it's got so much power.
It's just a crazy technique.
And I was raised in a taekwondo school that came from the old school taekwondo
before tournament's see General Che Che Hong Yee.
He trained,
he was the inventor of talk,
one of the founder of taekwondo and he trained a small handful of,
of,
of elite instructors.
And one of them was Jay Hahn.
Kim,
who was my instructor.
So my taekwondo background was the old school taekwondo.
Oh four Olympic.
It was even a consideration.
And so everyone trained for power.
It was a different thing.
Breaking.
Yeah,
it was just,
it was,
you had to be able to defend yourself in this treat.
My instructor,
his idea was if you couldn't hurt someone with a kick,
like why are you then practice it?
And these taekwondo guys and tournaments,
there weren't tapping each other.
They were just moving really fast trying to score points and he hated that shit.
He hated that shit and he felt like you had to load up more.
There had to be more power into those techniques.
And it wasn't quite as fast as like the,
the,
the really quick style Olympic point style taekwondo.
Yeah.
But that Olympic point style wouldn't hurt anybody.
You couldn't keep them of you.
But,
but the thing is hard for me,
like I tried to practice your ways,
but to have are,
I don't know if it's my hips or the way,
it's just,
it's just reps.
It's just repetition.
Okay,
we'll go over here after we're done.
It's freaking hard,
man.
This Jim here,
I'll,
I'll just give you a refresher.
Yeah.
A lot of it comes from the front leg side kick.
Nobody I know.
Do you know I go back,
I went back to karate training because I,
I've done more at but I was conferring from karate background and we've done it
straight.
Not Straight.
That had more Moight I don't,
I haven't done it for a kid begging for a long time cause they don't really do
that much and more.
They,
when I went back to karate,
my last fight and when I start to to Redo it,
I've been taught that again with their knee.
Yeah.
I liked your,
I liked the way you do it man.
Hey dra.
Yeah.
Then he has to be hired to get the full power into it.
I just don't have that same efficiency with it is great.
It can be done.
You can learn that efficiency shit a hundred percent it's freaking nuts man.
But it comes from learning first the right way to do the front leg side kick.
See the front leg side kick.
You developed a tomb that that knee comes up and then boom,
it's all in trust in that hip and pop it it forward.
And then once you develop the speed from doing that,
then you do it with the turn,
then it's turned boom.
It's the same thing.
It's that twist of the hip and the extension of the leg.
But then it's also the term first.
So the turn,
first boom,
and then the extension of the leg.
That's why that power comes from she,
it's all in a straight line.
And then the three 60 when the right leg is forward and you step forward and
then throw that was,
that's,
that's like getting hit by a train.
That's that one that I,
there's the strongest Cyrus is,
that shit's crazy.
You're running it somewhere.
You're not even in your prior mountain 50 shit.
Yeah,
but when I was 19 I could do it like a laser beam that is so fast,
you know like in that video.
I mean was just,
that's all I did though.
I mean what?
From the time I was 15 till the time I was 21 I didn't do shit.
I barely did any homework and then pay attention in school at all.
All I did was fight.
That's all I did was Daytop one though.
It's all I did.
I just want it to be in the Olympics.
I wanted to be a taekwondo champion.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's all I wanted to do it.
But then the problem was I started sparring with kickboxers getting fucked up
and I realized that taekwondo has no hands.
Like the hand techniques were useless.
And when I would be in a boxing ring and it would be sparring with someone,
they just get me in a corner.
It started fucking me up and I was like,
oh,
I don't know how to do this.
Like I need to learn how to box.
And so I realized taekwondo in a lot of situations is not effective.
It's not useful.
Yeah.
Like I needed to learn how to box first.
And so then I started training that and then I started getting dry train with
Moitai guys getting leg kicked.
I'm like,
ah fuck.
Cause we were doing like above the waist kickboxing and then I saw Rick Rufus
when he fought that a tie fighter,
you know,
this is like really important fight when Rick Fuck this guy and the guy just
chopped his fucking lays out Ronda.
I'm like,
ah,
I saw that fight.
However
you put the same fight in the,
in the MMA contest,
like,
I mean Rick roofers beat the shit out of him.
The first,
the first,
first I think few,
few,
a few minutes he killed a guy,
but the guy who was kind of the rules to stand back up then he a you.
Okay.
You put that in the MMA context.
That's why they're striking.
And MMA people say,
Oh,
let's say my,
whether it goes into MMA,
it'll knock everybody out if they stay standing.
I don't agree with that.
And that old man,
he'll get killed.
Even his legs,
not only the leg too.
I think even the,
the end that,
that uh,
like rent,
Ecuador beat by Victor Belfor.
Remember with the [inaudible] you say that in English,
like the boxing,
the dirty boxing,
boxing,
glitching is dif.
Very different.
Even the distance,
the timing with each has a small glove,
you know,
it changed everything for sure.
Then I spar,
I spar with much better decorated pure wrestler than me in,
in,
in MMA.
I put them all down.
Oh yeah.
All of them.
That because I'm better restaurants because my timing,
I learned from karate out to close the gap in karate,
but I use that,
I use a karate for the tech down.
Some use karate for a blitzing and like wonder boy she has,
depending how you use your tool,
you know what I mean?
What do you think about Wonderboy tilt?
That's this weekend.
Oh,
I love the man.
I got to watch his fights.
I think two things can happen.
How long are you going to be in town for a,
I leave on Friday.
I got to go back on Friday.
I'm questioning.
Gee,
yeah,
fights on Sunday.
It's here.
Yeah.
No,
it's an England.
But it's early March.
I'm going to do a fight companion.
Come in here and watch it.
I gotta,
I gotta.
I gotta have balance man.
And I wish I lost the receipt is because I really got to balance,
but they had this weekend.
I have some something important this weekend,
but then I need to be a much shoulder Saturday.
I would fights,
we'll do an internet,
that type of her like every night or watch fight with people that doesn't know
nothing about fight.
It's fucking for prisoners are fun.
We'd drink a couple beers,
watched the fight.
My fight companion are different than,
you know,
most of my friend are not really.
Fighters are like no more guys,
Geek geeks or whatever.
You know,
they think they know,
but they don't know that they get about fighters
the way they are freaking out.
I'd always,
and I've tried to be diplomatic.
I'm sitting here and everybody's like,
why you didn't do this white into now?
And I,
I used to try to correct them.
I used to,
but I put so much effort and energy that I just gave up.
I want point.
I'm like,
fight would live with wonder by people.
Like I was watching the fight.
He's like,
it's so boring I do it.
You just don't understand that with Wonderboy you go with one of the way and you
you,
you charge him like this.
He would.
You know what I mean?
Like I don't want to talk about,
he's my friend and I don't want to talk about for dare until if he listened to
this
round,
but they just don't freaking get it.
They don't understand.
They don't,
they're not educated about the,
the cultural like it's the same thing on the floor or there.
Why don't you do mood like and they have a few fights on the street.
That is,
it is funny though.
My boys man,
I like,
I liked it but a lot of them likes,
I was like,
man,
I listened.
Not all of them,
but some of them were like,
oh Geez,
is this is frustrating?
They take,
they know but they don't know man.
A lot of,
damn,
they think they know what they don't know why.
I said,
I love you guys,
but oh my God.
Going to be tied to oil.
You can,
you know.
Well,
this isn't George.
Let's wrap this up man.
Thank you for coming here.
I really appreciate it,
brother.
It's always great to say thank you man.
Thank you.
Is it the real time?
Real time.
Shoot.
I used to hear us by,
yeah,
we did three hours.
Oh my God.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
You sure can be the real time warp in here,
man.
Dude,
that's insane.
I need to beat the deck on today.
Let me check.
Where are you going to go?
I go to dad.
They contended with Freddie Roach.
What time does it take me there?
Yeah,
I'm checking that,
but you needed to train with me.
I need that.
I think I needed it to be there at four 30 before.
I think it closes at four 30 if you leave now,
you can be there by four 30 yeah,
but I missed that fricking back kick and structure and all that,
which I want to give you a quick one real quick.
Fuck.
That's fucking do it.
You don't mind
buddy.
You don't mind.